COMMITTEE ON RULES TO ORDER. A
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
GOING TO MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH OUR PROCESS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR
THOSE WHO MIGHT BE TUNING IN
FOR THE FIRST TIME. SOMEONE TO
COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR THE DAY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
IN TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WELL
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
TO THE PUBLIC- OF THE PUBLIC
EXCUSE ME. TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE FOUR
ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN
NINE EIGHT SEVEN IT'S ON THE
SCREEN IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE. AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE THIS AT LEAST
ONE MORE TIME ANA POSSIBLY TO
AS WE MOVE INTO THAT SEGMENT OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. WHEN WE
DO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LAN AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND O AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THIS
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR HELP IN THAT
REGARD. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO HAVE TO ADJUST TO OUR NEW
ONLINE TOOLS. SO AGAIN PLEASE
BE PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER. I'M GONNA ASK
ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
INCLUDED AND WITNESSES ALIKE.
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY IF
I NEED TO INTERRUPT YOU PLEASE
FORGIVE ME IT WILL BE BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOU ARE
WE HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY BUT YOU WILL GET TO
COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR- YOUR THOUGHTS- SO BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. OUT LET
ME LET MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
KNOW AND ANYONE WATCHING THAT-
SENATOR GROVE IS ALSO AT A
HEALTH COMMITTEE MEETING AT THE
SAME TIME- SO SHE WILL BE
COMING AND GOING- BUT THAT IS
THE REASON- SHE IS NOT PRESENT
IN THE BEGINNING- SO MADAM
SECRETARY WITH THAT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
KAMLAGER HERE KAMLAGER HERE
LAYERED HERE RIGHT HERE BATES
HERE BATES HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE. THANK YOU- WE HAVE
A LOT ON OUR AGENDA AND BEFORE
WE GET TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES ARM REQUIRED TO
APPEAR WITH YOUR ODD CONTINUED
INDULGENCE IMPATIENCE TO THE
TWO APPOINTEES HERE I'M GONNA
TRY TO DISPENSE WITH SOME-
BUSINESS- AND I'M GONNA TELL MY
COLLEAGUES I NEED TO WALK YOU
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE WE'VE
SEPARATED OUT A NUMBER OF
VOTES. SO I WILL TELL YOU WHAT
I NEED AND THEN- SEE WHO WILL
MAKE THAT MOTION- I'M GOING TO
GO TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND ARE
ASKED THAT WE TAKE UP ITEM TO
SEE ANDY AND THESE ARE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WOULD ENTERTAIN ALONG
WITH SOME OF THANK YOU SENATOR
WE CALL THE ROLL. ROVE KAMLAGER
I LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES I DEFY ATKINS HI THAT'S
INSIDE. THANK YOU THE ROLE WILL
REMAIN OPEN- WITH SENATOR GROVE
NOT PRESENT BUT FOR MEMBERS
VOTING IN SUPPORT. I WILL TAKE
UP ITEM TO- E. F. G. AND H. AND
THAT WOULD BE. MEMBERS TO THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
COUNCIL ALL FOUR. ARE YOU HAVE
THAT BEFORE YOU I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION SO MOVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH KAMLAGER HERE I. LONGER
I LAYERED FIVE I BATES GAINES
EIGHTH AT. NOON FALCONS. ARE
HERE AND ALSO I. AND IT THAT
WILL REMAIN OPEN. FOR THE
AGENDA FOR CENTER GROVE TO ADD
ON LET'S SEE I AM HAPPY TO-
ENTERTAIN ITEM NUMBER FOUR BILL
REFERRALS YOU KNOW- WAIT I'M
GOING TO THREE RIGHT. YES THANK
YOU SORRY I GOT CONFUSED WITH
THE HERE AND THE ICE- SO WE
WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
FOR VOTE ONLY AND AS A
REMINDER- THESE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD THAT
YOU HEARD EXTENSIVE COMMENTS-
TESTIMONY QUESTIONS ON AT THE
LAST MEETING- AND SO THAT WOULD
BE I'M GOING TO SEPARATE HESE
VOTES AS WELL. AND I WOULD TAKE
A MOTION ON- THREE I N. J. THAT
WOULD BE JOHN BOMBS- AND DIVINI
HURT FOR MEMBER OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION I WOULD SOME. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY THREE I AND J.
KAMLAGER I AM LONGER I LAYERED
ON AYE BATES OF STATE THE SEX
THING. ATKINS HI INSIDE THANK
YOU AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
R. AS WELL- ITEMS THREE. K. AND
L. THAT WOULD BE GIDEON KRAKOFF
AND TANTI WAS LIKE SEPARATING
ALL THREE OF THOSE KILLED BOTH
THROUGH KAHLER TOGETHER
TOGETHER OKAY- SO AGAIN FORGIVE
ME- ITEMS THREE K. AND L.
GIDEON KRAKOFF AND TANIYA PUT
J. O. WARNER ALSO MEMBERS OF
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. A
MOTION WITH SOME THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY
WE CALL THE ROLL GROWTH
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI THERE
HI THERE I BATES ALL RIGHT IT'S
AYE ATKINS HI I THINK SIDE
THANK YOU AND WE WILL KEEP
ITEMS THREE QUE EN EL OPEN AS
WELL- I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM. FOR THAT WOULD
BE BILL REFERRALS. OUR WITH
SOME OF THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED- SIR. GROWTH I'M LONGER
HI ROBERT I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ALL RIGHT I CAN FIND AT
INSIDE WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
AS WELL FOR SENATOR GROWTH TO
ADD ON- THE LAST ITEM BEFORE WE
MOVE INTO OUR HEARING PART OF
THE MEETING- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THE RETIRED IN NEWINGTON AND
THAT IS TO APPROVED ANY OR PAYS
A TO RETURN AS RETARDED
NEWINGTON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE
OF A HUNDRED NINETY DAYS. FROM
THE DATE OF RETIREMENT I WOULD
MOVE THAT THANK YOU SENATOR A
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE I WOULD MOVE ON AND WE'LL
COME BACK AND GET LETTER GET
IT. HELLO KAMLAGER HI MARGARET
I LAYERED HI THERE I BATES
RIGHT. I ATKINS HI I CAN SAY
AND WE JUST HAD A MOTION THAT
THAT IT'S NOT REALLY 51% OF THE
STATE'S OIL PRODUCTION IS FROM
KERN COUNTY AND- IT'S AHEAD FOR
NOTHING RIGHT. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL AND WITH RESPECT
AND COURTESY TO OUR COLLEAGUE
WE WILL MOVE ON AND WE WILL
GIVE HER TIME TO CATCH HER
BREATH AND- WE WILL COME BACK
AND PICK UP FOR VOTES ON ALL
THOSE THINGS. OUT LATER IN THE
MEETING- SO WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO THE FIRST GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
I AND THAT WOULD BE CAROL VINNY
WHO IS GENERAL COUNSEL AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. OUT WELCOME AND LET
ME SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXTREME PATIENCE ALTHOUGH GIVEN
YOUR JOB I IMAGINE PATIENTS IS
REQUIRED- WE WANT TO WELCOME
YOU. AND I ASK YOU TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT'S
WITH YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO JOIN
YOU TODAY THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON TIME
ACTIONS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT IS AN HONOR TO BE
HERE WITH YOU TODAY. I WANT TO
THANK EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING YOUR STAFF AND
THEIR ON GOING SUPPORT OF THE
CLAIMANTS I HAVE REACHED OUT TO
YOUR OFFICES. IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE DURING THE ENDEMIC.
I WAS HONORED AND HUMBLED TO
HAVE RECEIVED THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT AND I THANK HIM FOR
ENTRUSTING ME TO DO THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. WHEN THOSE
APPOINTED ALONGSIDE ME UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE DIRECTOR
SIGNS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO INTRODUCE
THOSE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
PRESENT WITH ME TODAY IF WE
WERE IN PERSON MY AMAZING
PARTNER AMIR. I AM CREDIBLE
CHILD ALEX AND MY WONDERFUL
PARENTS JUST A FEW NOT ASSEMBLY
PRO WATCHING FROM DOWNSTAIRS
AND DOWN THE STREET
RESPECTIVELY FOR ALL THEIR LOVE
THEIR ENCOURAGEMENT AND THEIR
SUPPORT. THEY HAVE MADE MORE
SACRIFICES THAN I CAN COUNT AND
I AM FOREVER GRATEFUL TO THEM
FOR HAVING GIVEN ME EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN TO GROW
AND TO POUR MYSELF INTO THIS
WORK. ESPECIALLY NOW WHEN SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON EDT.
I HAVE DEDICATED MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY. FIRST THRILLED
OCCASIONAL TRAINING AND FOR THE
LAST FOURTEEN YEARS THROUGH
LEGAL ADVOCACY AND I BRING THIS
TO MY ROLE AS GENERAL COUNSEL.
WE OFTEN REFERRED TO THE
BENEFITS IMMEDIATE MINISTERS AS
A SAFETY NET BUT TO SO MANY WHO
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
THESE BENEFITS ARE REALLY A
LIFELINE ENSURING ECONOMIC
STABILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
MOMENTS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
DISABILITY OR FAMILIAL CARE
OBLIGATIONS. THERE IS NO OTHER
PLACE I WOULD RATHER WORK RIGHT
NOW THEN I ET DE GIVEN HOW
CRITICAL THESE WAGE REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS ARE. MY VERY FIRST
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MATTER
DATES BACK TO TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX WHEN I WAS STILL IN LAW
SCHOOL. BUT MY ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE NEEDY AND ERNEST BEGAN ON
THE HEELS OF THE GREAT
RECESSION WHEN I WAS WORKING AS
AN ATTORNEY IN A LEGAL SERVICES
NONPROFIT PROVIDING ADVICE AND
REPRESENTATION TO HUNDREDS OF
CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE BEEN
DISQUALIFIED. FROM RECEIVING
BENEFITS. I DEVELOP LEGAL
EXPERTISE IN THE AREA OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE LONG BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY I EXPERIENCED
THROUGH MY CLIENTS. THE ONGOING
FRUSTRATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS. AND THE
DESPERATE FEAR OF LOSING THE
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS BY THEIR
ABILITY TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. I CARRY THESE
EXPERIENCES ALONG WITH THE
EXPERIENCES OF THOUSANDS OF LOW
WAGE AND IMMIGRANT WORKERS WHO
MIGHT HAVE SERVED OVER MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER. TOGETHER
WITH THOSE OF MY OWN IMMIGRANT
FAMILY I WILL CONTINUE TO BRING
THIS LANDS TO MY JOB AS GENERAL
COUNSEL AS I WORK TO ACHIEVE-COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE LAWS. ENSURE DUE PROCESS
FOR CLAIMANTS AND EMPLOYERS
ALIKE. TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT AND ABOVE ALL LEVELS
ENHANCE THE CLAIM EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING IMPROVE ACCESS TO
BENEFITS FOR THOSE WHO FACE
BURGER BARRIERS. THE MISSION OF
THE LEGAL OFFICES SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT AND ITS UNEMPLOYMENT
DISABILITY WORK FOR SERVICES
AND TAX BRANCHES TO ENSURE THAT
LAWS ARE CORRECTLY INTERPRETED
CONSISTENTLY APPLIED AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED. THE
OFFICE PROTECTS THE INTERESTS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS BY ENSURING
THAT CRUCIAL SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COMPLICATED WAY A FEDERAL AND
STATE REQUIREMENTS. IT IS OUR
ROLE TO HELP TRAIN OUR STAFF ON
THESE REQUIREMENTS AND TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO COMMUNICATE
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND NON
LEGAL TERMS TO CLAIMANTS. WE
ARE WORKING TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL RISKS TRY TO MITIGATE
LEGAL LIABILITIES AND AVOID
DISPUTES. WE ALSO REPRESENT
MEDIAN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEEDINGS AND SUPPORT THE
ATTORNEYS WHO REPRESENT THE
DEPARTMENT INSULIN COURT. AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORS
WHO REPRESENTS THE STATE'S
INTEREST IN CRIMINAL MATTERS.
THE PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT NEW
CHALLENGES TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND EACH CHALLENGE. PRISMS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGAL
OFFICE TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENT
IS FOLLOWING ALL THE RULES AND
SERVING THE PUBLIC ATTRACTIVELY.
PENDING LITIGATION ASIDE WHICH
I CANNOT DISCUSS SINCE MY
APPOINTMENT SOME OF OUR KEY
ACHIEVEMENTS MILLEDGEVILLE
OFFICE TODAY. I HAVE BEEN
EXPLORING EFFICIENCIES IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
SYSTEM AND FINDING WAYS TO
STREAMLINE THE DETERMINATIONS
PROCESS WHILE STILL MEETING ALL
THE REQUIREMENTS UNDER LAW.
ESTABLISHING NEW DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS TO HELP DETECT FRAUD
AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE AND I MAKE BENEFIT
FRAUD. AN IMPROVING NOTICES THE
CLAIMANTS. SO THEY COMMUNICATE
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED LAWS AND
PLAIN LANGUAGE SO THAT
CLAIMANTS BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS HAPPENING WHAT IS NEXT
AND WHAT IS EXPECTED OF THEM.
AND REDUCING BARRIERS TO
GETTING BENEFITS BUT THE MAJOR
FOCUS ON LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
CLAIMANTS THE COMMUNITY THAT I
HAVE SERVED. FOR THE ENTIRETY
OF MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER AND
FOR WHOM WITH WHOM I HAVE
IDENTIFIED FOR SOME OF MY LIFE.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE WORK
AHEAD AND I AM COMMITTED
TOGETHER WITH THE LEADERSHIP D.
D. TO BRING ABOUT DIGNITY AND
SECURITY TO CALIFORNIANS WHEN
THEY ARE NOT WORKING. IF
CONFIRMED I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
BOLD LEADER IS THE DEDICATED
STAFF I EDT. ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS PARTNER SISTER
AGENCIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE. THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING ALL OF
YOU TO ENSURE THAT YOU DO DE
DELIVERS ON ITS MISSION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIA TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS AND THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR FOR ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
IN YOUR THOUGHTS- CENTER
LAYERED YOU WANT TO GO FIRST.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR- R. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR MEETING
AND WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
IN A OF YOUR ADDRESS SOME OF
THE THINGS I MIGHT WANT TO HAVE
TALKED ABOUT IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT AND I SHOULD NOTE
THAT YOU WERE APPOINTED FIVE
MONTHS INTO THE PANDEMIC AND
HAND SO. SORT OF THE DIE WAS
CAST WITH THE D. D. AT THAT
POINT BAND. R. S. AND I KNOW
LOTS OF US HAVE DIFFERENT
EFFORTS DID TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
THE LONG TERM. BUT YOU ARE
GENERAL COUNSEL AND- THEREFORE
YOU HAVE- A DISTINCT SLICE OF
THIS AND WHEN WE HAD OUR
CONVERSATION YOU INDICATED THAT
THERE WERE TEN BRANCHES. AND
ALL THE ATTORNEYS WERE GENERAL
COUNSEL AND YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT A REORGANIZATION OR RE
DEPLOYMENT THAT MIGHT PUT. THE
ATTORNEYS IN THE INDIVIDUAL
BRANCHES DIRECTLY COULD YOU
JUST TALK ABOUT THAT- AND
WHETHER THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE DETERMINED IN
YOUR PARK IF YOU D. D. THAT YOU
THINK SHOULD BE REORGANIZED.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYER I
REALLY SINCERELY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY- SO
RIGHT NOW THE LEGAL OFFICE IS-
ITS OWN. UNIT WITHIN THE
DIRECTOR'S OFFICE AND ONE THING
THAT I HAVE FOUND TO BE SO
VALUABLE IS- THE DEDICATION OF
ATTORNEYS I HAD BEEN SUPPORTING
THE PROGRAMS AND- IT WOULD BE.
REALLY BENEFICIAL TO CONTINUE
THE INTEGRATION- AND TO HAVE
ATTORNEYS REALLY BE YOU KNOW.
IT CAN IN THE PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT THEM TO HELP-
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES TO BETTER
IDENTIFY ISSUES BEFORE THEY
BECOME PROBLEMS AND TO CONTINUE
THE PARTNERSHIP- YOU KNOW AND
TO STAY INTEGRATED IN THE WORK
OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND THEN OF
THERE HAS THERE WAS A STRIKE
TEAM THAT WAS PUT INTO E. D. D.
VAN THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES IDENTIFIED BY THEM WHEN
YOU WALKED IN THE DOOR. OUR
GOAL IS TO LEGAL UNIT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A DRESSING SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT MIGHT HAVE
COME UP IN THAT PROCESS. YES WE
ACTUALLY ALL POURED OVER THE
STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS
TOGETHER WE SPENT SEVERAL I'LL
STAFF MEETINGS DISCUSSING THEM
BRIEFING EACH OTHER ON THEM-
FINDING WAYS THAT THEY'LL THE
LEGAL OFFICE. THAT COULD HELP
IMPLEMENT MANY OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. YOU KNOW OUR
ROLE IS TO IS TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT AND IN EACH OF THE
BRANCHES AND- WE HAVE WE HAVE
STRIVED AND SUCCEEDED IN IN
DOING THAT A FEW OF THE STRIKE
TO RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
DIRECTLY TOUCHED- INCLUDE. YOU
KNOW REVIEWING THE REGULATIONS
AROUND THE USE OF AN IDENTITY
VERIFICATION- PROCESS ID ME
SPECIFICALLY. WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO IMPROVE GUIDANCE AND
COMMUNICATIONS WITH CLAIMANTS-
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW WE MAY
GRANT- REVISIONS TO THE
INFAMOUS NOTICE OF AWARD-
REFERENCED IN THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT. WE'VE ALSO WORKED
REALLY HARD TO REDUCE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS AS I MENTIONED
SPECIFICALLY WITH THAT WITH AN
EMPHASIS ARAMBULA THE LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT CLAIMANTS.
WHO WHO FACE HURDLES IN
CONTACTING AND COMMUNICATING
EFFECTIVELY. WITH THE NEEDY. DO
YOU THINK SOME OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS- ARE NOW BEING
IMPLEMENTED WOULD REALLY CHANGE
WHAT THE REACTION IS OF THE
DEPARTMENT IF YOU WERE TO
PLUNGE INTO. THE SIMILAR
SITUATION AGAIN. ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THE STRIKE RECOMMEND WERE-
YOU KNOW WELL WELL RECEIVED BY
EDT AND WE ARE CONSTANTLY IN
THE PROCESS WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED- FULLY MORE THAN
HALF- THE REST ARE ALL UNDER
WAY AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK TO
LOOK AND SEE. HAVE WE BEEN ABLE
TO MEET THE INTENT AND THE
SPIRIT OF THE RECOMMENDATION-
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CHANGING A
POLICY YOU KNOW THAT IT IT
ACTUALLY PERMEATES DOWN AND
LEADS TO MEANINGFUL CHANGE- YOU
KNOW ONE EXAMPLE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE ACCESS
PIECE. YOU KNOW THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO CHANGE
THE POLICY ABOUT WHEN TO USE
INTERPRETIVE SERVICES AND THE
POLICY WAS CHANGED AND WE
DIDN'T SEE THE OBJECT THAT WE
ANTICIPATED AND SO WE REALIZED
WE NEEDED TO DO MORE- AND SO WE
INCREASED OUR OUR CONTRACT WITH
OUR THIRD PARTY VENDOR WHO'S
WHO PROVIDED INTERPRETER
SERVICES. AND UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR EEO OFFICER
WE- BEGAN A TRAINING MODULE SO
THAT ALL- ALL THOSE WHO ARE
CLAIMING FACING WITHIN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE RENTS
ARE TRAINED IN HOW TO USE
INTERPRETER. IT'S A SKILL IT'S
A SKILL THAT ONE LEARNS- AND SO
WE REALIZED THAT WE NEEDED TO
DO MORE WE HAD ALREADY MET THE
RECOMMENDATION BUT WE WANTED TO
GO. ABOVE AND BEYOND AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE WANT YOU KNOW WE
REALLY MET THE ENTANGLE OF THAT
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU-
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
TO. THE DIRECTOR BOUGHT FONG. A
LOT OF US HAVE. LEGISLATION OR
WILL BE VOTING ON LEGISLATION I
MEAN IT ON DOING A BILL THAT
REQUIRES. A RECESSION PLANNED
SO WE NEVER GOING TO RECESSION
AGAIN WITHOUT E. D. D. R.
HAVING A PLAN IN PLACE AND AS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT IF YOU SEE WAYS THAT
YOU THINK THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE ENGAGING THAT WE
DON'T SEE THAT YOU WOULD
CONTINUE ALONG WITH THE
DIRECTOR TO BE IN CONTACT WITH
US BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO GO
THROUGH. OF THE SITUATION AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS I REALLY APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM VICE
CHAIR. I BELIEVE THAT MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE TO MY RIGHT. SENATOR
LAYERED ACTUALLY COVERED THE
ISSUES THAT TAUGHT SOME OF
THOSE ARE MORE IN DEPTH THAN WE
DID WHEN WE HAD THAT MEETING
THIS MORNING AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PROVIDING THAT TIME ON
WHICH TO FIT TO ME AND I'LL
LONG ABOUT EARLY MORNING ARE
TODAY AND WE COVERED MANY OF
THE ISSUES BUT- ONE THAT STILL
STANDS OUT- THAT I WANTED. I
GUESS DIG A LITTLE DEEPER INTO
WAS THE DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE WITH THAT CDC ARE
AND I KNOW THAT WAS KIND OF
YOUR ON YOUR RESPONSIBILITY IF
I REMEMBER CORRECTLY THAT THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT YOU WERE A
SET DATE WITH YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE LEGAL
ISSUE TO GET ENAMEL YOU IT
SEEMS TO HAVE TAKEN A LITTLE
LONGER THAN ONE WOULD HAVE
HOPED FOR BECAUSE IT STARTED IN
SEPTEMBER AND I THINK THAT. IT
WAS FINALIZED SOMETIME IN
DECEMBER WHICH WAS SOMEWHAT ODD
SO THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF RESISTANCE ON THE
PART OF CDC ARE MAYBE PRIVACY
ISSUES AND ALL OF THAT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT CERTAINLY THAT
TERM UNFORTUNATELY I STILL HAVE
HAD MANY CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE
CONTACTING ME REGARDING THEIR
EDT ACCOUNT FROZEN BECAUSE THEY
WERE TOLD- THAT THEY WERE IN
PRISON AND DO YOU TO- I STAFF
WORKING DILIGENTLY WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET THROUGH OF SOME OF
THOSE TO CLEAR UP MANY OF THE
ACCOUNTS HOWEVER- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROCESS CDD
HAS PUT IN PLACE TO ASSIST. WE
DEVELOPMENT CLAIMANTS ARE
RESOLVED THEIR CASES WHEN THEY
ARE FLAG THIS POTENTIAL FRAUD
AND I KNOW THAT SPAN AGAIN
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
PROCESS SO THAT OUR DISTRICT
STAFF'S MIND IN PARTICULAR AND
I KNOW THAT I SHARED THIS WITH
ALL OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THEY'RE BASICALLY
ALMOST PRO BONO WORKERS FOR.
EDT CLAIMS AND A U. I. B.
CLAIMS EXCUSE ME AND IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF THERE'S A PROCESS
IN PLACE THAT A CLAIMANT CAN GO
DIRECTLY THROUGH EDT AND GET
THAT RESOLVED RATHER THAN- OF
HAVING TO BE THE INTERMEDIARY
FOR THEM BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE
OBVIOUSLY- FOR MANY WHO HAVE
JUST APPLIED. AND ARE. BASED ON
SOME OF THE- STAFF REPORTS AND
GET. IT FILLED BETTER BUT WE
SEE HAVE ONES THAT GO WAY BACK
AND I THINK THOSE ARE ONES THAT
ARE STILL. PROBABLY WOUND UP IN
SOME OF THE FRAUD ISSUE SO-
COULD YOU GIVE A LITTLE MORE IN
DEPTH DISCUSSION ON THE PROCESS
THAT EDT IS USING TO. ASSIST
THE CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE HAD.
THEIR KEY FLAGGED AS A
POTENTIAL FRAUD AND- PERHAPS-
TIED UP WITH THE- THE- THOSE
WHO WERE IN PRISON IN HAND ON
THESE. THEIR VIEWS THEIR
IDENTITY TO OBVIOUSLY-
ILLEGALLY GOT TO MAKE A CLAIM
AND ACTUALLY RECEIVE BENEFITS.
ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING- SO JUST BRIEFLY ON THE
CDCR DATA SHARING AGREEMENT YES
IT WAS ENTERED INTO INTO IN
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR- AND IT
HAS ALLOWED EDT TO- TO CLEARLY
SEE DATA AND ANALYZE IT AGAINST
OUR CLAIM AT POPULATION. AND WE
DO THIS VERY REGULARLY- WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT THE DATA
IS NOT AS CLEAN- AS AS WE WOULD
HAVE HOPED- AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE CHECKED AGAINST MANY.
MORE WAYS OF IDENTIFYING A
CLAIM IT BECAUSE AT THE DATA
CAN BE IN PERFECT SHOULD ALSO
SUPPLEMENTED THAT DATA WITH A
REGULAR CHECKS AGAINST. A THIRD
PARTY VENDOR AT THOMSON REUTERS.
ALLOWS US TO ALSO LOOK AT-
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AND
ACROSS OTHER STATES AS WELL AS
SOME COUNTY JAILS IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT THE
PROCESS HAS BEEN- CLOSELY
REVIEWED IT TO ENSURE DUE
PROCESS TO ALL CLAIMANTS- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT. WE GET AND TRY
TO MAKE A REASONABLE CONTACT
WITH THE CLAIM IT BEFORE THEY
ARE DISQUALIFIED FROM RECEIVING
BENEFITS AND AROUND THE ISSUE
OF INCARCERATIONS IT'S SUCH A
TRICKY ONE BECAUSE BEING
INCARCERATED- WHILE RECEIVING
BENEFITS IS THAT- AWAY MEANS TO
DISQUALIFY HAVING BEEN
INCARCERATED IN THE PAST ISN'T.
AND WHAT WE'RE ALSO LEARNING-
IS THAT THE DATES OF
INCARCERATION ARE ALWAYS WHAT
THEY APPEAR TO BE. AND SO IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTACT CLEMENS AND CLARIFIED
THAT INFORMATION- BUT BEFORE-
IT LEADS TO DISQUALIFICATION OF
COURSE THAT WORKS ABOUT THE
CLAIM IT DOESN'T HAVE TO APPEAL
AND GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS AS
WELL. WITHOUT DOUBT GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL IF THE THAT GET
SOME REFINED IS SO THAT A CLAIM
IS GOING DIRECTLY TO EDT AND-
THEN THAT FLAG SOLVE THE
SITUATION AND IT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO BE RESOLVED I WOULD THINK.
PRETTY QUICKLY WHEREAS RIGHT
NOW IT'S STILL. TAKING AN
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
I DO APPRECIATE TOM THE WORK
THAT YOU ARE TAKING ON A BIG
JOB AND IT DID VERY DIFFICULT
ONE WHEN YOU HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
SEEMS TO BE SO UPSIDE DOWN. IN
ARE BEING INUNDATED AND IN A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WITH
WHAT THE CLAIMS AND PROBABLY AN
ANTIQUATED- TECHNOLOGY AND I
THINK WE SHARED OUR DISCUSSION
ABOUT ALL YOU KNOW MORNING CALL
SO. WITHOUT ALL ON BEHALF. OF
THE MICROPHONE ON. TO MIKE. WHO
CONTINUE TO. BUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE ASKING QUESTIONS
AND- FOR OUR VERY- GOOD
CONVERSATION IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION AS WELL THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM PRETEND
MISS BEING IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU SENATOR YEAH TO
SPEAK WITH ME YESTERDAY I
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION- I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU
TOOK WITH ME AND- I WHAT WAS
ACTUALLY SHOCKED THAT YOU'D
ONLY BEEN IN THE ROLE SINCE
SEPTEMBER. DID MAKE THE COMMENT
THAT. YOU TOOK THIS JOB IN
SEPTEMBER. KNOWING AT LEAST
HAVING SOME IDEA OF KNOWING
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING INTO WITH
THE HOT BETTER HOT MESS THAT WE
FIND EDT. AND I WAS. VERY
INTRIGUED AND IN PHYSICALLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT YOUR RESPONSE-
BECAUSE I CAN'T IMAGINE THE
MOUNTAINS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MOVE TO MAKE THIS
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH A
DIRECTOR SIGNS BOTH OF YOU. I
THINK THAT WAS A GOOD
APPOINTMENT AS WELL. TO WORK
WITH DIRECTOR SIGNS TO- FIX THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE AT T.
AND LIKE I SAID I APPRECIATED
AND WAS ENTHUSIASTIC OF YOUR
RESPONSES YOU IMMEDIATELY
RESPONDED THAT. YOU LOVE A GOOD
CHALLENGE AND EVERY CHALLENGE
CREATES OPPORTUNITY. AND SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I AM. IN
THE REAL WORLD I GUESS YOU
WOULD SAY I'M I'M AN EMPLOYER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SO EDT IS A WHEEL HOUSE- IN ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE WORK
WITHIN IN THE EMPLOYMENT AND-
IN HIM IN PRIVATE BUSINESS. AND
THAT HR FIVE DEFENDER FOODIE
CITY JUST GOES ON AND ON BUT
THIS ACTUALLY IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART BECAUSE I WAS A BUSINESS
OWNER THAT SURVIVED THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THE Y. FRENCH-
YOU I TRUST FUND DEBT THAT HIT
EMPLOYERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
BECAUSE OF THAT GREAT
RECESSION. EVAC THEN I BELIEVE
IT WAS ABOUT ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IT TOOK SEVEN YEARS TO
PAY IT OFF VISITED ADDITIONAL
EXPENSE AND ADDITIONAL TAX TO
ALL BUSINESSES IN THESTATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW IN SOME WAY
EMPLOYERS IN THAT SPECIFIC
SITUATION HAD- SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT THEY EITHER COULDN'T
MAINTAIN BUSINESS- BECAUSE OF
THE SITUATION THE ECONOMY AND-
THEY HAD TO LAY OFF INDIVIDUALS
BUT IN THIS CASE. THIS
SITUATION WE FACE TODAY IS AT
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN THESE
EMPLOYERS DID NOT LADIES
EMPLOYEES OFF WILLINGLY THEIR
JOBS WERE DEEMED NONESSENTIAL
THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
WORK IN BENEFITS FOR PROVIDED
AND TO THE U. I TRUST FUND PAN
AND ALSO. SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS
WERE PROVIDED. THERE'S AN S.
THAT THERE TWENTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT I'M AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT'S
TWENTY FOUR BILLION WITH A B.
DOLLARS IN DEBT- FOR THE U. Y.
TRES FRIEND. WHAT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. CONCERNED
THAT UNLESS CALIFORNIANS YOU
AYE LOAN IS FORGIVEN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
DIVERT SOME OF THE STATE'S
BUDGET SURPLUS TO PAY OFF THE
Y. DEBT AND EMPLOYERS THAT HAVE
STRUGGLED TO SURVIVE UNDER THE
PANDEMIC RULES- AND THE EVER
CHANGING PANDEMIC RULES. AND
THE HORRIFIC YOUR THAT JUST WE
JUST CAME OUT OF UNDER TWENTY
TWENTY AND WILL BE SADDLED WITH
THIS OF YOU KNOW HUGE DEBT SO I
GUESS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS WITH THIS
GREAT OPPORTUNITY BEFORE YOU.
THAT AND- YOU HAVE- REGARDING
THE U. I TRUST FUND DEBT AND
THAT INSTEAD OF PUTTING THAT
TAX BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS. SO I
JUST WANTED TO GO BACK AND
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT THANK YOU
I TRUST FUND WENT INSOLVENT
PRETTY EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC- AND MUCH LIKE THE
GREAT RECESSION WE'RE SEEING-
THE BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT.
BACK CALIFORNIA ISN'T ALONE
THERE'S OVER TWENTY OTHER
STATES IN THIS PREDICAMENT-
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I'M YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY THE LOVE.
THE FEDERAL UNDER PENDING OF
THE SYSTEM IS ON- IS ON THE
BACKS OF THE- YOU KNOW IT AND-
I DON'T THINK ANYONE COULD HAVE
A- A PANDEMIC LIKE THOSE.
CERTAINLY BUT THAT IS A- THE
LEGAL FRAME OF HOW THE FUN IS
FINANCED AND SO I- ENCOURAGE
SOME SOME. TO THE FEDERAL ON
THE. I THINK YOU'RE A PRE THAT-
IT IS A- I THINK DON'T AND- I
DON'T KNOW FOR MICHAEL IN THIS
LET UNDER. THAT AND- AGAIN
EMPLOYERS HAD NO. THEY HAD NO
CONTROL OVER THE BENEFITS BEING
ISSUED BECAUSE YOU KNOW
RIGHTFULLY BENEFITS NEEDED TO
BE TAKEN CARE OF SO PEOPLE
COULD STILL CONTINUED WITH FOOD
ON THE TABLE BUT THEY HAD NO
CONTROL- ANOTHER THING THEY HAD
NO CONTROL OVER IS THE JOBS
BEING DEEMED A SIMS ASCENTIAL
ESSENTIAL OR NOT BE INDEED
DEEMED ESSENTIAL AND THE OTHER
ISSUE THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
THE ONGOING CONTINUING THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR WEEK EDITION ALL OF. YOU
I FUNDS BEING DISBURSED-
WINNING PLAYERS ARE BANKING AND
DOING HIRING BONUSES AND PAYING
EXTRA MONEY AND FOR PEOPLE TO
COME BACK TO WORK BUT THOSE
BENEFITS ARE STILL BEING PAID
OUT AND IT'S THAT IT'S NOT JUST
OUR STATE OTHER STATES ARE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK WITH A
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS. AND I
DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO BE IN YOU
KNOW MISUNDERSTAND THAT- IT'S
ONLY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS- IS
IT THREE DOLLARS. IN THE STATE
OR IS A SIX ENDER. IT'S
CURRENTLY HUNDRED DOLLARS THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO I A MISSILE
ANYBODY. IF SOMEBODY'S DRY. SIX
CENTER FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR A
WEEK ARE. THIS IS IN A- THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK SO. IF
IT'S SIX HUNDRED AND IT'S THREE
HUNDRED THAT'S BASICALLY TWENTY
TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR TO STAY AT
HOME. WITH SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS- ON THE OTHER PARTS
THE FIVE OR SIX CENTER THAT
THEY'RE DRYING- WILL GIVE
PLAYERS CAN ACTUALLY TURN INTO
YOUR DEPARTMENT TO SAY. I
OFFERED MISS CAT MISS CALLAMARD
DAD A JOB AND SHE DECLINED IT
AND THEN. YOU GUYS WOULD
INQUIRE WHY SHE DECLINED IT SHE
MAY HAVE A VALID REASON WHICH
WOULD ALLOW HER TO CONTINUE
BENEFITS. BUT IF SHE DIDN'T
HAVE A VALID REASON A REASON
WAS- IT'S ONLY BECAUSE I'M
GETTING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS AND ET DE. THAT
SHOULDN'T BE A REASON FOR
PEOPLE TO DECLINE EMPLOYMENT
THAT'S READILY AVAILABLE FOR
THEM. TO HELP OUR ECONOMY
IMPROVE. AND WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. THAT'S A- CAR
ACTION- REFUSAL. AT TO WORK AS
A RE. OF RECEIVING MORE ON. IS
NOT CAN- OF THE A GOOD IT. A
GOOD REASON- TO NOT GO BACK TO
WORK IT AND JUST. TAKE A STEP
BACK I JUST WANTED TO ALSO
POINT OUT THAT THE MAXIMUM IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THE AVERAGE PERSON
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS ACTUALLY
RECEIVING. UNDER THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A WEEK CURRENTLY- AND
SO WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL.
BENEFITS THAT ARE COMING FROM
THE FEDERAL STATE. WE'RE
LOOKING AT A TOTAL OF YOU KNOW.
UNDER HUNDRED- WEEK FOR THE FOR
THE COUPLE. THAT'S NO THANK YOU
M. SO I DON'T KNOW IF MASTER
MISTRESSES FOR DOLLARS AN HOUR
FOR FORTY DOLLARS A WEEK SO
EMPLOYERS- OF. IN ORDER TO
ENTICE THEM WE NEED TO PAY
MAKES MAKE SURE THAT EVEN LIKE
FAST FOOD AND STUFF IS MORE
THAN FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR- I
SO AGAIN I DO HAVE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS MEMBER TIM I'M SORRY
AS- DO YOU ANTICIPATE- IS THERE
I MEAN IS. IS IS THERE AN
ANTICIPATION THAT THE
ADDITIONAL YOU AYE BENEFITS
WILL CONTINUE TO GO OUT AGAIN.
THE TRUST FUND IS ROUGHLY DO
YOU KNOW WHAT THEIR CURRENT
BALANCES I'VE HEARD DIFFERENT
NUMBERS. THE LAST NUMBER I
HEARD WAS TWENTY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION. SO IT'S TWENTY
ONE POINT THREE BILLION- AGAIN
ALL EMPLOYER FUNDED. AT ALL
EMPLOYER FUNDED- AND AGAIN THE
EMPLOYERS DIDN'T HAVE A LOT TO
DO ON THIS NOT WITH THE
INCREASE BENEFITS OR THAT. YOU
ARE BENEFITS PAID OUT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE AND THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES CONTINUING TO GO AND
IF SO FOR HOW LONG. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE FEDERAL
BENEFITS. YES THE ADDITIONAL
YEAH- SO RIGHT NOW THEY ARE-%
THEY'RE ALLOWED THROUGH
SEPTEMBER- AND IT'S ANYONE'S
GUESS WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL DO- COME
SEPTEMBER I'VE HEARD I'VE HEARD
BOTH WAYS SO I CAN'T SAY FOR
CERTAIN. I WAS HOPING YOU HAD
AN INSIDE TRACK. IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY I'VE HEARD ALSO
THAT THERE'S A- THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL AND
WILL AND I DON'T SEE FOR GIFT
BUT- AT THE END. NOT CHARGE THE
TAX CREDIT TERM AS UPON OR IS
THAT NOT TRUE. MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY WAIVING
THE INTEREST- THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD OTHERWISE BE
PAYING- AND I BELIEVE THE LAST
INTEREST PAYMENT WOULD HAVE
BEEN APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE.
MILLION DOLLARS- SO I DO KNOW
OF THAT WAIVER- I CAN'T SAY IF
THERE IS ANY PLANS TO REDUCE.
THE TAX. I GUESS IN THE FUTURE
SO THERE WE'VE THE INTO BUT THE
NOT THE PRINCIPLE. THAT'S MY
UNDER THAT'S- SO THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
EMPLOYMENT TRUST OR YOU I TRUST
FUND BENEFITS IT'S OVER DRAFTED
THERE'S AN ESTIMATE OUT THERE-
THAT FRAUDULENT CLAIMS BASED ON
THE EDT IS NINE POINT 7% WHICH
IS ELEVEN POINT ONE. AND
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS HALF
OF THIS YOU ARE TRESPASSING
OVERDRAFT SO I MEAN JUST YOUR
THOUGHTS AND I KNOW YOU CAN'T
MAKE THAT DECISION BUT JUST
YOUR THOUGHTS DO YOU THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE
TO PAY BACK FRAUDULENT BENEFITS
THAT WERE PAID OUT THAT THEY
AGAIN HAD NO CONTROL OR
RESPONSIBILITY OVER. YES I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE A STEP BACK IN
AND TALK ABOUT THAT NUMBER- THE
ELEVEN POINTONE THAT YOU WOULD
LOSE IT TOO. THE MAJORITY OF
THAT 95% OF THAT ACTUALLY WAS
PAID OUT ON. PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE THIS IS
A FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT WAS
CREATED- BY THAT CARES ACT IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND
ALLOW US FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T
QUALIFY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE INCLUDING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS RECEIVE- THOSE
MONIES SO THE LARGE MAJORITY OF
THE FRAUD THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED AS ALL OTHER STATES
HAVE BEEN THEM BACK PROGRAM AND
SO THAT WILL ACTUALLY NOT HAVE
ANY DIRECT IMPACT ON THE U. I
TRUST FUND ITSELF- IT'S JUST
THE REMAINING 5% SO MUCH
SMALLER PIE- THAT WAS. THAT WAS
PAID OUT. 5% OF THE U. I TRY
FUND OKAY 5% THE THIRTY BILLION.
A 5% OF THE L. BEFORE PERCENT
ELEVEN BILLION OKAY THANK YOU
FOR HELPING ME UNDERSTAND THAT
I APPRECIATE THAT. I AM. DO YOU
I MEAN I KNOW WE STILL HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO BEFORE THIS IS
ALL CALCULATED OUT BUT BASED ON
LIKE A DO YOU GUYS DO LIKE I
DON'T KNOW M. LIKE FORECASTING
OR YOU KNOW LIKE WE DO
FORECASTING AND IN PRIVATE
BUSINESS ABOUT YOU KNOW IF WE
MAINTAIN THESE BILLABLE HOURS
YOU MAINTAIN THESE CLIENTS
ESTIMATED REVENUE IN THE THIRD
QUARTER WILL BE THIS SO WE NEED
TO PREPARE FOR TAXES FOR THAT
SO IN THE SAME THING DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDT- DO
FORECASTING ON WHAT THEY THINK
THAT END RESULT OF THIS YOU I
TRUST FUND DEBT WILL BE. AND AT.
AT THE END OF THIS PANDEMIC
SEASON OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
GUESS NOW. YEAH THAT'S A
TERRIFIC QUESTION I
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T- KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT BUT I CAN REACH
OUT TO OUR COLLEAGUES. IN THE
FINANCE UNIT TO FIND OUT FOR
YOU IF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
OKAY NO I APPRECIATE THAT. WE
TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU GUYS ARE
PUTTING IN PLACE TO PREVENT
FRAUD. AND I REALIZE IT IS
EIGHT EIGHT ON. THE BALANCING
ACT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE THAT DON'T DESERVE
BENEFITS THAT ARE FRAUDULENTLY
APPLYING FOR BENEFITS ARE
DENIED BENEFITS LIKE TE- GUY
THAT STARTED IN ORGANIZATION
INVITE FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN BENEFITS AND- ACTUALLY DO
DOWN TWO POINT EIGHT. MILLION
FIVE MILLION A BENEFIT STREET
pBEFORE IT WAS ACTUALLY. VESTED
IT WAS ISN'T INDIVIDUAL IS AN-
AND- SO WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
PEOPLE THAT. BENEFITS AND- GET
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THEY GET
THEIR BENEFITS THERE'S NONE OF
US WHO THINK ANY DIFFERENT THAN
THAT. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE THAT DON'T
DESERVE BENEFITS DON'T GET THE
BENEFITS- THAT. THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN APPLYING FOR
THAT SHOULDN'T ARE NOT ENTITLED
TO BENEFITS I GUESS YOU'D SAY.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING TO ME
YESTERDAY- CALLED ID ME AND I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY TOUCHED ON IT BUT CAN
YOU GO THROUGH THE IDEA ME
PROCESS FOR ME AND LET ME KNOW
ANYTHING YOUR PERCENTAGES TODAY
BUT I DON'T QUITE REMEMBER.
WHAT IT WAS ABOUT THE FRAUD
THAT THAT HAS ACTUALLY
PREVENTED SO I APPLAUD YOU GUYS
FOR PUTTING THAT TOGETHER SO
CAN YOU GO THROUGH WHAT I DID
MEANS. ABSOLUTELY I WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO. ASK FOR
THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS TO
AB DE UM AND EDB. CONTRACTOR
BUT I DO NEED A STARTER KNOCKED.
OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEY ARE
AN IDENTITY PROOFING- SERVICE
AND SO THEY ARE ABLE TO
AUTHENTICATE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S APPLYING. FOR
BENEFITS IS IN FACT WHO THEY
SAY THEY ARE- AND- ACCORDING
TO. THEIR INFORMATION THEY ARE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY. THAT YEAH.
FOX FRAUD AND THAT NUMBER IS
QUITE HIGH- IT APPEARS THAT
THEY'VE PREVENTED- THERE
ESTIMATES OVER 30% OF
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS THAT WOULD
HAVE. BEEN FILED IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. M. THE THAT'S GOOD
THAT THAT'S A WAY THAT- THAT
ANY ID ME BECAUSE- REQUIRE LIKE
AN ID LIKE YOU JUST MAKE SURE
THE PERSON APPLYING IS THE PER
WHO'S ACTUALLY APPLYING- NOW
THERE ARE THERE ARE DEFINITELY.
ID REQUIREMENTS- SO THEY AND IT
DEPENDS ON HOW THERE'S TWO WAYS
THE PROCESS COULD GO- BUT THERE
IS A PROCESS BY WHICH- THE
ACTUAL IDEAS IS PROVIDED- AND
IF FOR WHATEVER REASON THE ID
CAN BE PROVIDED IF THERE IS A
VIDEO ONE ON ONE. WITH ONE OF
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES CALL THE
TRUST THE TRUST. TAG VISUALLY
AND YOU AND THE IDEA THE SAME.
TIME OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY- YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO
THE WAY FROM IN THE FROM HEAD.
DO YOU REQUIREMENTS I IT'S ON
THE AND IT TO A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF STAFF TIME TO RECOVER
A BENEFITS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
PAID OUT- AND IS THERE GOING TO
BE IS OUR PLAN TO HAVE STAFF
DEDICATED TO PURSUE THOSE WHO
COMMITTED PRADA THERE THAN OUR
LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE
DOING IT NOW WITH THE PRISON
SYSTEM. BUT IS THERE A PLAN TO
ALLOW STAFFERS TO PUT STAFF ON
A ON A YOU KNOW RECOVERY. OF
FRAUD BENEFIT PAYMENTS. AFTER
SO IT'S JUST AS TO WHAT THE
PROCESS THERE IS A- ON BEHALF
OF. DEPARTMENT TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT THE DEFERRED WORKLOAD
FROM TWENTY TWENTY- THAT WAS
ONE OF THAT THE C. ESTATE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL- AND
THAT PLAN IS IN PLACE CURRENT.
IS BEING DEVELOPED CURRENTLY
AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS THE
TERMINATIONS WILL BE MADE IN
CASES OF OVERPAYMENTS- THOSE
WILL BE ESTABLISHED. WE'LL HAVE
TO LOOK TO SEE WHETHER THERE
WAS FRAUD AND SALT- AND IF
THERE WASN'T SPEND A WAIVER IS.
IS POSSIBLE BUT IN CASES OF
FRAUD- THE COLLECTIONS PROCESS
WILL START. WELL THANK YOU MUCH.
M. WE- A FEW CALL COMMENTS WITH
MIKE FROM WHERE COUNTY AND VICE
CHAIR. ABOUT CRY REFERENCE SEEN
IN- WITH C. IN IMAGE THAT THERE
WERE A- ASSEMBLY THAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION TO I IT WAS IN A-
THAT MY COLLEAGUES AND OTHER
SIDE I'LL ASK ME TO TAKE AND I
WERE WITH HIM TO HIM. BECAUSE I
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT IT BUT HE
SAID SOMETHING ABOUT DOES THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ARE NOT
ALWAYS- ACCURATE CAN YOU GIVE
ME A LITTLE DETAIL ON THAT. YES
SO WHAT WE'VE LEARNED- THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF CROSS MATCHING
IS THAT WE NEED TO. TO MATCH
MUCH MORE THAN JUST ONE- AND
THEN A FIRE- WE NEED TO
CROSSMATCH ACROSS MULTIPLE
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T. A
VERIFICATION OF THE INFORMATION
THAT IS PROVIDED- BY. BY THE-
CORRECTIONAL DEPARTMENT AND SO.
WE CAN'T COMPLETELY RELY ON IT
IF WE ONLY USE ONE DATA SOURCE.
THAT'S PRETTY SCARY. YEAH I
MEAN I THINK THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL TO MAKE ERRORS AND WE
WANT TO AVOID ABSOLUTELY AND SO
WE'RE PUTTING IN GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME INDIVIDUAL
BECAUSE- WITHOUT THAT
INFORMATION BEING VERIFIED WE
COULD ACCIDENTALLY- DISQUALIFY
SOMEONE WHO IS A 100% ELIGIBLE
FOR BENEFITS AND WE ABSOLUTELY
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT
ABSOLUTELY I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU SO ON A PERSONAL NOTE
IN THIS MAY BE TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE FOR ME TO ASK YOU
THIS QUESTION. I HAVE I MEAN IF
IT IS YOU CAN TONIGHT ANSWER
THE SENATE PRO TEM CAN CORRECT
ME- THE I HAVE A- SB THIRTY
NINE IT'S GOING TO THE BUILDING
WHICH ACTUALLY CROSSED REQUIRES
A CROSS MATCHING TO TAKE PLACE
WHAT ARE AND IF THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE TO THE
POINT THAT WE THINK IT SHOULD
BE LIKE MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
AND M. IN IN CUSTODY DON'T GET
BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ENTITLED TO BENEFITS BUT THOSE
THAT ARE RELEASED FROM CUSTODY
OR IN CUSTODY. AS WE THINK
ABOUT IT YOU AYE BENEFITS ARE
PAID TWELVE MONTHS IN THE REARS
RIGHT SO FOR THAT OUR WORK THAT
HAS DONE THAN THE YEAR BEFORE-
IF YOU GET PUT IN JAIL- UNLESS
YOU'RE IT'S ILLEGAL FOR YOU TO
DROP BENEFITS WHICH I DON'T
THINK IT IS BETTER AND IF YOU
GET PUT IN PRISON YOU CAN STILL
DRIVE BENEFITS AT YOUR-
EARLIEST STAGES IN PRISON
BECAUSE YOU HAD WORK- PRIOR TO.
CORRECT THANK YOU. CHOOSING
THIS ISSUE THIS IS A REAL
INTERESTING POINT WITH THE
NUMBER. AND LAW- SO. THE
BENEFIT COULD GUESTS THAT A
CLAIM COULD BE- THAT THE ISSUE
WOULD BE CARDS. AS A YOU'RE NOT
ABLE AND IF. TO WORK- AND THAT
WOULD BE THE DISCO. FACTOR IN
SO- BE. IN CARS IN ITSELF IS
NOT- BUT AN ISSUE IF IT'S- IN
THE- IT'S- THE- OF. BY AT THE
TIME OF IN CAR. THAT IS.
ILLEGAL IS. PHILIP ME TAKE A
JUST A STEP FURTHER BECAUSE
THAT IT'S A FOR TIME I'VE HAD
THAT THAT RECENT- THAT- SENDING
HE- IN PLYMOUTH. SO IF I IF I
TAKE IT JUST ONE STEP. AND I
SAY- SOME JUST SEE. DOES
COMMITS A CRIME GETS CONVICTED
GOES TO PER SLUSH JUST SAY FOR
YEARS K. THREE YEARS WHATEVER.
AND THAT TIME FRAME. THE
EMPLOYER STILL PAY SEVEN I MEAN
ALREADY PAID SEVEN POINT
PERCENT. OF THAT EMPLOYEES UP
TO THE FIRST STEP THOUSAND.
WHICH WOULD GRAYSON ENTIRE THAT
PERSON TO BEND. DO THEY GET TO
THOSE BY IT'S IT AFTER. AND
THEY GET OUT OF. OR AT OF IT
BEING A CAR. SO THAT THEY CAN.
YOU KNOW FEEL THEIR FAMILY OR
WHATEVER AND TELL WHAT THE-
TELL FIND IN THAT JOB THEY'RE
STILL ELIGIBLE THOSE BEEN. OVER
OR NO. THAT'S IT AND THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION SO I'M VERY. HOW
ABOUT THAT. THE PER IS IN CARS.
FOR NEXT. PERIOD OF TIME- AND
THE BASE. AT THE BASE. IT IS.
USUALLY EIGHT. MY PRICE. TO THE
TO THE RECEIPT OF BENEFITS- AND
SO THAT. FOR WHAT QUALIFY-
BENEFITS MY LIKELY. THEY
HAVEN'T WORKED IN. THE RISK
HISTORY. IS THERE ANYTHING IT
LIKE CAN YOU TELL WHAT YOU'RE
DOING FOR. AND THIRD- AND THIRD.
I SAID OF ID'S AND JUST NOT TO
READ ON C. ARE. M. FOR
PERSONALLY LIKE TO HELP MY BILL
BE MORE ACCURATE. I THINK I
THINK WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO-
GUARD AS I REFERRED THEM EARLY-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
LOOK AT MORE DATA THE JUST A
SOCIAL SECURITY. BE IT'S NOT
ALL ACCURATE- AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING THERE CAREFULLY TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE- REFERRING TO
THE SAME INTO- BUT I CAN. THINK
ON IT- AND PROVIDE ANY SUGGEST
THAT I WOULD BE HELD BUT I DO
THINK THAT THE CROSS HAS.
ULTIMATELY UNSUCCESSFUL AND
WILL CAN TO REFER OUR- TO MAKE
IT PERFECT AND WE DID YOU START
THAT PROCESS AND I'M BACK IN.
THE CROSS STRETCHING'S- AFTER
THE SOME- AFTER DECEMBER SO
THREE. THIS OKAY SO THAT'S-
OKAY AND SO IN YOU WEREN'T YOU
NOT BOUND TO STATUTES TO DO IT
THE BILL WOULD RE. YOU GO TO
CAN TO DO IT. AND WHAT ARE SOME
OF GUARDRAIL THAT YOU CHECK NOW.
TO MAKE SURE SOMEBODY THE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT IF. DOESN'T GET
TO BUT IF. S. SO. ONE OF MY OF
THE FIRST OF WE DO AS WE IN
THAT. THEY MULTIPLE DAY POINTS
THAT ARE CROSS. OUR ARE A LOT-
SO IT'S NOT JUST RELYING ON THE
NON BUT OTHER. OTHER THAT CAN
BE PROVIDED AS WELL. SO THAT
ONE WAY TO THAT WE- BOTH
TALKING ABOUT SAME AND- THE
OTHER OF. IS AT A INTERVIEW
PROCESS- REQUEST. THE WE ENGAGE
WITH- THE CLAIM. AND SEE
CONFIRM- SO THAT WE CAN BE CALM.
THAT THE INFORMATION THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO US CAN BE
RELIED UPON TO DISQUALIFY A
CLAIMANT. THE PRAYER TO GET IN
LATER I ENTER PEOPLE JOB FOR
THIRTY YEARS- WHAT DATA POINTS.
I'M NOT SURE IF I CAN DISCLOSE
BUT AT THE DATA BUT I. OKAY
I'LL TAKE THAT THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THOUGHT WELL OKAY WHAT'S POINTS
AND I. THAT VERY AND- THE YOU
FOR TAKING MY QUESTIONS YOU FOR
THE LOVELY MEETING- YESTERDAY-
AGAIN. HE AND DIRECTOR SIGNS AG
ME HOPE THAT EDT WILL- THE
ISSUES THIS DEPARTMENT WILL BE
RESOLVED AND- I APPRECIATE YOU
AND YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON
THIS POSITION- I THINK WHEN
THEY DO THAT SWEARING IN IF
THEY SWEAR YOU IN YOU KNOW.
THAT YOU TAKE THIS JOB WITHOUT
ANY MENTAL RESERVATION OR
PURPOSE OF EVASION. BASED ON
WHAT WE ALL KNOW WHAT YOU'RE IN
FOR I'D BE QUESTIONING YOU ON
THAT SPECIFIC. PIECE BUT I AND
ECSTATICALLY EXCITED THAT YOU
HAVE TAKEN ON THIS CHALLENGING
YOU SEE IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FIX. THE STATE'S EDM MAKE SURE
PEOPLE GET BENEFITS THEY
DESERVE BENEFITS. EMPLOYERS ARE
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
BENEFITS THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW PAID OUT- LIKE
THE YOU THAT. THE U. A. P. FANS
AND THEN- I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU. ANSWERING ALL MY QUESTIONS
TODAY THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR- I
HAVE A FEELING THAT SOME PEOPLE
QUESTION US ON THAT OKAY WELL
BUT HIGH STATE I. DO IT INTO
DIRECTIONS LIKE THEY UNDERSTAND
SOME OF US TAKE THE- THAN
OTHERS THERE- INQUISITIVE. I
SENATOR COME LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I TO WANT TO-
THING YOU FOR TO TIME THIS MORE-
TO MEET WITH ME AND ACTUALLY-
YES ON A DISTRICT THIS IS THAT
I BEEN HAVE WITH EDT- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE- YOUR CANDOR
AND YOUR HONESTY AND- YOUR
BREVITY- AND I WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES BY
GIVING YOU AN ENORMOUS CREDIT.
FOR WANTING TO TAKE ON THIS JOB
AFTER MANY OF IT THE FONG
DYSFUNCTIONS OF EDT WERE
REVEALED SO KUDOS. TO YOU-
REALLY BECAUSE I'VE THAT ONE OF
YOUR- TASKS NOW IS TO HELP-
REBUILD THE CRISIS OF TRUST
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT- AND- WITH EDT- YOU
KNOW BUT I. I TRUST THAT- THERE
WILL BE SOME HOPE WITH YOU
BECAUSE I THINK FOLKS JUST WANT.
HONEST AND TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATION THAT THEY CAN
DIGEST- AND THAT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN RELY ON. SO WHEN WE
TALKED I ASKED YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT I WANT TO JUST
TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF THEM ONE
WAS ABOUT- THE CONTRACT WITH
BANK OF AMERICA- AND I KNOW
SOME OF IT- SOME OF THE ISSUES
WERE AS A SORT OF ABOUT FRAUD
BUT ALSO ABOUT YOU KNOW. THE
FREEZING OF- THESE LOADED CARDS.
LOADED WITH BENEFITS- SOME
QUESTIONS AROUND SORT OF THIS
REVENUE SHARING CLAUSE- WITH
THE STATE. AND THEN QUESTIONS
AROUND THE INTEREST THAT BANK
OF AMERICA WAS EARNING ON THESE
CARDS WHILE THEY WERE BEING
FROZEN SO I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T
REALLY SPEAK TO. BUT JUST
WANTED YOUR THOUGHTS ON- ANY
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THIS-
RELATIONSHIP FROM THIS CONTRACT
WITH BANK OF AMERICA. AND WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN RIGHT THE SHIP-
AS WE WORK WITH FUTURE VENDORS.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF FOR YOUR
TIME AS WELL AND FOR THAT
QUESTION WE HAVE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY- OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WITH BANK OF AMERICA TO
INSURE THE ELIGIBLE CLAIMANTS
WHOSE CARDS WERE IMPROPERLY
FROZEN HAVE BEEN UNFROZEN OUT
WE HAVE YOU KNOW THE-
VISIBILITY INTO TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS. EDT HAS
VISIBILITY INTO YOUR YOU KNOW
THE U. I CLAIM IT AND THEIR
IDENTITY- AND OTHER IN OTHER
WAYS OF THAT THE PERSON IS
ELIGIBLE BANK OF AMERICA ON THE
OTHER HAND HOUSE TRANSACTIONAL
HISTORY INFORMATION THAT WE ARE
NOT PRIVY TO WE HAVE DIFFERENT
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS AND WE HAVE
WORKED REALLY HARD. SO THAT WE
CAN- RESPECTIVELY MEET EACH
OTHER IN OUR OWN. WITHOUT
INTERFERING WITH EACH OTHER'S.
I WOULD SAY THAT OF- THE
SILVERLIGHT. IN IN THE
SITUATION WAS THAT YOU DID WAS
ABLE TO END UP. HEY CLAIMANTS
WHO THEY DEEMED ELIGIBLE- THE
EDGE- BECAUSE IS A TECHNO INC.
THAT INSURERS. THAT WHEN A CARD
IS FOR A EVAN ARE NOT LOADED A-
AND SO. FOR CLAIMANTS- YOU KNOW
EATING ABLE TO CONTINUE MEETING
IT'S LEGALIZED. OF WHEN DO-
BECAUSE OF THE. AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THROUGH.
THOSE THIS- AND WE HAVE MADE
GOOD FOR. AND I THINK WE ARE. A
MUCH STRONGER- AS A RESULT OF
THOSE I'M GOING COMMERCE. TODAY
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
I'M SOME PEOPLE WOULD NOT UPSET
IF A WE ENDED UP GO WITH
ANOTHER MAN. TO HELP US IN THE
FUTURE- YOU KNOW I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD YOUR
THOUGHTS ON- HOW VULNERABLE EDT
IS- TO. CLASS I LAW- ON THE ONE
HAND POTENTIALLY FROM WORKERS
WHO MAY FEEL LIKE THEY'VE BEEN
ASKED TO DO THINGS THAT THEY
HAD NOT SIGNED UP TO DO WHEN
THEY WERE FIRST HIRED- GIVEN
THE ENORMITY OF- ISSUES EDT HAS
FACED. OF THE PANDEMIC- AND
THEN ALSO FROM CLAIMANTS WHO
FEEL LIKE- THEY'VE BEEN
UNJUSTLY TREATED- EITHER
THROUGH THAT YOU KNOW- NOT
GETTING THEIR BENEFITS IN TIME
THE ISSUES THAT FOLKS HAVE HAD
WITH THE THIRD PARTY REVIEW
PROCESS GIVEN THEY HAVE TO
SHARE THIS INFORMATION MULTIPLE
TIMES AND WERE ABLE TO YOU KNOW
HAVE THEM VERIFY AND THEN RE
VERIFY. THEIR EXISTENCE IN
TRUTH IDENTIFICATION- I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED WHEN WE TALKED
THAT THERE WERE A COUPLE OF-
CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS- ALREADY
WE'RE EVD- HAS BEEN MENTIONED
AND SO OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T GO
INTO THE DETAILS BUT- YOU KNOW
HOW VULNERABLE ARE WE TO ANY
ADDITIONAL ONES- OR TO SOME OF
THESE THAT MAY POP UP THAT
HAVEN'T- JUST YET BECAUSE I
THINK. THE OTHER PART OF THE
QUESTION IS THEN HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE
SO THAT WE DO NOT- INCREASE OUR
EXPOSURE. ALSO REALLY GREAT THE
ANSWER SOME THAT I HAVE. VERY
HARD AT WORK IN IDENTIFYING
POTENTIAL RISKS- TO AVOID
FUTURE EXPOSURE AND WE ARE
TAKING PROACTIVE MEASURES
WHATEVER WE CAN TO- TO TOW IT
SO TO RIGHT ANY WRONGS AND- WE
ARE- I FEEL LIKE WE ARE IN. A
GOOD POSITION- WE HAVE- THE
DONE. IF I'D- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WE THINK ARE THE RISKS
HAVE MADE- STEPS TO IN THE AT.
THANK ARE THINGS CONTINUE TO
RAMP. SOUNDS I TELL YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT SOME CAR LAWSUIT
NEAR FAMILY TALK ABOUT THAT.
IT'S GOT ITS THE LAWYER IN YOUR
OUT- YOU KNOW WORK FOR ME CLASS
OF. IS ALSO A REAL BIG THING
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S THAT YOU
ARE PAY. ABOUT WANTED JUST- HE
YOUR WRIST TO- HOW PANDEMIC
HASN'T. WORK PERMITS CLASS OF.
MAYBE THE CHAO. THAT HAVE-
ERUPT AS A RESULT OF YOU KNOW
THE CONTINUING AROUND AB FIVE-
AND THEN THAT SORT OF YOU KNOW-
COME.BY THE PANDEMIC.
ABSOLUTELY AND THE UNITED ARAB
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST OF MISS
CLASSIFICATION ARE ARE NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART I HAVE WORKED
ON BEHALF OF MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS I AM FOR MUCH OF MY
CAREER- AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO ENFORCE THE LAWS
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE MISS
CLASSIFICATION DOES REALLY HURT
THE STATE IT HURTS BUT THE
CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A VERY ARDUOUS PROCESS
TO BE FOUND ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS TO ESTABLISH THAT THEY
WERE IN FACT EMPLOYEES- BUT
ALSO IT HURTS. THE COMPLYING
BUSINESSES THE ONES THAT ARE
ARE PAYING INTO THE FUND- AND
SO THIS IS CERTAINLY AN AREA OF
PRIORITY OF OURS- AND WE HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME STRIDES
IN THIS AREA I THINK THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE WILL
BE HELPFUL BEFORE I JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY UNDER COMMON LAW
TESTS- YOU KNOW IT WAS IT WAS
IT AS THE COURTS HAVE POINTED
OUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
INCONSISTENT RESULTS AND WITH
THE THREE PART TEST I'M GOING
FORWARD. WE REALLY HOPE TO HAVE
MORE CONSISTENT OUTCOMES IN
THESE MATTERS WHICH I THINK
WILL BE HELPFUL. TO EVERYBODY.
HAVING MORE. AS TO WHAT IS. AND
WE IS AN PER UNDER LAW. YEAH
YEAH. YOU KNOW I INTRIGUED BY
THE SERIES OF COURSE THAT MY-
COLLEAGUES BIGGEST WITHOUT A-
FULL WHO ARE INCARCERATED THE
FRAUD- BECAUSE IT IS TRUE THAT
WE WANT SO WHO ARE. HAVE WORKED
FOR THEIR BEEN AND DESERVE
THEIR BENEFITS TO GET IT- TAKE
THEM IT'S ALSO I THINK
IMPORTANT I. TO AND I SHARED
WITH THE STATE ON AND SOMEONE
ELSE EDT AT ANOTHER HEARING I
WAS ON THIS- IN THE ASSEMBLY IS
THEY'RE ALSO A NUMBER OF A
PHONE WHO IN FOR A WHO WERE
VICTIMS IDENTITY THEFT- AND SO
THEIR INFORMATION WAS ACTUALLY
USED. A FRAUDULENTLY TO COLLECT
BENEFITS AND I ALSO HAVE TO
ASSUME THAT JUST AS A MATTER OF
TIMING THERE ARE PROBABLY SOME
FOLKS WHO- DID WERE. AND
PROBABLY WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS. AND WITH. WITH IN THE
LEGITIMATE PERIOD OF TIME WERE
EITHER ARRESTED OR ENDED UP IN
JAIL- OR MAYBE IN PRISON
ALTHOUGH. PRISON MIGHT BE
HARDER TO. RECONCILE BECAUSE IT
DOES TAKE AWHILE FOR YOU TO GET
THERE IT'S JUST NOT YOU KNOW HE
DO SOMETHING BAD ON TUESDAY AND
GO TO PRISON ON WEDNESDAY- SO.
I ALSO HOPE THAT THERE'S
THOUGHT GIVEN TO THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME FOLKS
WHO MAY HAVE ENDED UP IN JAIL
OR IN PRISON. MORE LIKELY IN
JAIL- THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS AND IF THERE ARE WAYS
THAT THOSE CAN BE. TRANSFERRED
I GUESS WITH THEIR APPROVAL OR
SHARED TO FAMILY MEMBERS-
BECAUSE WHEN FOLKS ARE LOCKED
UP YOU KNOW. THEIR FAMILY-
MEMBERS ARE ALSO SUFFERING- AS
A RESULT OF THAT PERSON- YOU
KNOW NOT BEING ABLE TO WORK.
I'M I JUST YOU KNOW. WANTED TO
SHARE. WITH YOU THAT.
UNEMPLOYMENT AND YOU KNOW THIS
I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS FROM OUR
DISCUSSION IS SO IMPORTANT. YOU
KNOW I REMEMBER GROWING UP MY
MOTHER IS AN ACTRESS AND SO
THAT MEANS SHE'S A SEASONAL
WORKER. AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WAS PART OF OUR
EXISTENCE I KNEW WHEN SHE
STOPPED WORKING THAT SHE
STOPPED GETTING A PAYCHECK IN
THE NEXT PAYCHECK SHE WOULD
GET. QUOTE UNQUOTE PAYCHECK WAS
GONNA COME FROM UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND I KNEW THAT WHEN SHE WAS ON
ON EMPLOYMENT. WE HAD TO BE
REALLY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE
FOOD THAT SHE PURCHASED IN OUR
CONSUMPTION. AND THAT MEANT HOW
MUCH MORE OFTEN WE WOULD GO TO
THRIFT STORES- AND THE THINGS
THAT I. DECIDED THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR. BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
AFFORD. AND WE LIVE WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT IN OUR LIVES FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. WHILE I WAS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. AND IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND IN THE
BEGINNING OF HIGH SCHOOL. IT
WAS PART OF HOW WE SURVIVED.
AND I SHARE THAT BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
PROBABLY HAVE A SIMILAR STORY.
AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE IF MY
MOM. WAS NOT ABLE TO GET HER
CHECK. THAT SHE NEEDED. TO FEED
HER ONLY CHILD. AND SO I THINK
ABOUT THAT STORY WHEN THE
CONSTITUENTS CALL MY ACTIONS.
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF WE DIDN'T EIGHT. AND
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF FOLKS. ARE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH- BUT I
BELIEVE ACTUALLY THAT YOU ALSO
BELIEVE THAT AND I CAN HEAR IT
IN THE RESPONSES. THAT YOU
SHARED AND SO I TOO AM
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT YOUR CONTINUED
PRESENCE WITH EDIE D. N. WHEN
YOU ARE WORKING THROUGH HOW TO
RE FRAME AND REDESIGN. THE
LEGAL ELEMENTS OF EDG. THAT
MAYBE YOU REMEMBER THE STORY
FROM THE SENATOR FROM LA. THE
HELP FUEL THE PASSION THAT YOU
HAVE FOR HELPING US FIX THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR SO MANY PEOPLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
SHOWING THAT I WILL CARRY THAT
WITH ME AS WELL. US SENATOR
GROVE WOULD LIKE TO ASK ONE
MORE QUESTION PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TEN AM THANK YOU AND I HAD A
QUESTION I HAVE IS ONLY BECAUSE
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT AFTER WE HAD
A THAT LIKELY CONVERSATION.
WHEN THE ERRORS THAT-
VIEWFINDER EDT FINES WITH CDC
ARE AT THE DATA DO YOU TAKE
THAT BACK TO CDC ARE SO THEY
CAN RECONCILE THAT DAD AND IT
DOESN'T CONTINUE. I WILL HAVE
TO TAKE THAT QUESTION BACK-
SAID TO THE PROGRAMS AND I WHAT
I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU I'D BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- SENATORS IDEA
APPRECIATE ALL THE QUESTIONS-
AND ALL AND THE DISCUSSION. SO
I DON'T FEEL COMPELLED TO ADD
ON TO THE QUESTIONS. I WILL SAY
I A I CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN TERMS OF. YOUR RESPONSES AND
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS JUST IN IN
THE DIALOGUE TODAY PLUS.
LOOKING AT YOUR BACKGROUND AND
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU APPROACH
THIS WITH- WITH THE NEEDS OF
THE- THE EMPLOYEES WHO COUNT ON
YOUR SERVICES IN MIND SO. WITH
THAT I AM GOING TO MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO. ARMS COMMENT TODAY AND AS A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WHO WILL
PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
GOING TO APPEAR AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. AND THAT ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN
NINE EIGHT SEVEN AGAIN IT IS ON
OUR WEBSITE. AND WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
IN SPPORT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. AND INVITE
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE HERE TO
SPEAK. TO THE PODIUM. SEEING NO
ONE APPROACHING IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. I'M GOING TO GO TO
OUR SECOND ROOM WHICH IS ROOM
ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WAITING THERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE MIKE SO I'M
GOING TO WELCOME OUR MODERATOR
WHO WILL JOIN US NOW. AND ASK
THAT THE MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
GET IF YOU DO HAVE A QUESTION
PLEASE PRESS- SKEWS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
MODERATOR SOMEBODY WITH ENOUGH
THANK YOU- I'M GONNA MAKE ONE
COMMENT- BEFORE WE OPEN IT TO
TESTIMONY. AND THAT IS TO THE
WITNESSES WE ASK THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK YOU PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT. VERY BRIEFLY-
AND AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY SO MISTER
MODERATOR WITH THAT PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE TO CALL THE SUPPORT.
WITNESSES AND WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK I WILL GO TO THIRTY. IF
THERE'S ANY MORE PART. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIRTY. FOR AFTERNOON
MATTER CHIANG TO KEEP AND BEAR
ON. OF THE PORT EDUCATION AT
THE END OF. BROTHERHOOD OF. WE
ARE HERE AND SUPPORT. I THINK
YOU ALL SEEN HOW LET WE ARE
HAPPY. HOW SOMEONE. BE ME-
THIRD AT THE IMPORTANT TIME. TO
LEAVE ON THE HER COMPANIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO.
AND THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRAY ONE TO PAPA COM. MATTER
CHAIR THERE NO OTHER PER
QUEUING UP THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER WILL BE BACK YOU AND-
I HAVEN'T- THE SUPPORT SIDE WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PER.
AND HEAR FROM A- SO WILL BE
WITH A IN ROOM THREE ONE NOW
ONE. AND I ARE SEE THE THERE IS
NO ONE HE ADDITIONAL TO-
TESTIFY SOMEONE AGAIN JUST TO
BE SURE ROOM ONE TWELVE. I'D
SEE ANYONE APPROACHING IN ONE
TWO SOME MODEL WE ARE BACK WITH
YOU. TO SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO- TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO SO AN OPERATOR CAN GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
I MEDICARE NOBODY IS KILLING
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL- TALK WITH YOU SHORTLY I'M
SURE- I'M GONNA COME BACK INTO
THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE
ARE FURTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ARE A MOTION TO BE MADE. OKAY I
SENATOR GROWTH HAS MADE A
MOTION ON MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH GROWTH I KAMLAGER I'VE
LOVE HER I. BY I BATES I HAVE
AYE THAT'S FIVE FIVE ZERO THAT
IS YOUR WITH OUR
CONGRATULATIONS ON OUR- FOR
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WONDERFUL- WE ARE TO US BREAK
BEFORE WE DO I JUST IN THE INTO
ON TO SEE- CENTER GROVER READY
AND WILL WALK YOU THROUGH WE
DID A LOT OF SEPARATIONS. SO
AS- MADAM SECRETARY OPENS THE
ROLE FOR YOU- I WILL ASK OUR
HER TO DO IT IN THE ORDER THAT
WE TOOK IT AND. I'LL JUST
CLARIFY IF I NEED TO. SO MANY
SECRETARY YOU THROUGH THE LIST
WILL TAKE IT ONE OF A TIME.
ITEM TO SEE D. AND THAT IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINT NOT TO
APPEAR ARE HOUSING FINANCE.
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. I WROTE I
GROW BY FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO THAT IS COMPLETE THANK
YOU. NEXT ITEM ITEMS E. THROUGH
H. THOSE ARE THE VERIFY MENDON
HOUSING COUNCIL MEMBERS. OPEN
THE ROLE WROTE NOT VOTING ROAF
NOT VOTING THANK YOU AND THAT
WOULD BE REALLY TWO ZERO THREE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU THAT MOTION-
PASSES ARE GO HEAD MEDICAL
AFFAIRS THREE I AND J. THEY ARE
THOMAS. YOUR RESOURCES. AND
MEDINA HER- RESOURCES. SO WE'VE
BEEN ROLES YEAH. OKAY DO YOU
NEED THAT SEPARATED NOT OKAY.
GROWTH NO GROWTH NO. THAT THREE
TWO ONE OKAY UP WITH OF STATE
OKAY AND THAT PASS- GO MADAM
THREE K. AND L. GIDEON. AND
CHECK A TONYA PICTURE WERNER-
RESOURCE. FOR OPEN THE ROLE. I
GREW AS FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
FIVE DIZZY THAT IS OUT- ITEM
NUMBER OF IS BILL WERE. OF THE
ROLE ROOF HI RUTH I FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU THAT IS A AND THE
ITEM IS ITEM FOR THREE AND DO
IT TO. I WHICH IS OR SUCH A
RETURN INTUITIVE RULES FROM
PART OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
FROM THE DAY OF RETURN. ROVE
ABSOLUTELY WHEN HUNDRED PER. OF
I THINK THAT'S ENOUGH. FIVE
ZERO TWO- WE WERE COME THAT IN
THROUGH- IN THE VO. I THINK
THAT IS EVERYTHING RIGHT SO WE
WILL TO A FIVE MINUTE READ AND
THANK YOU THE LOZANO YOUR
PATIENCE WILL BE THE IN FIVE
MINUTES AND THANK YOU MISTAKING
AND CAN. FOR MINUTES.
AND CALL
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE BACK
TO ORDER. AND COLLEAGUES I'M
GOING TO ASK- WITH COURTESY TO
OUR COLLEAGUE WHO- WOULD AVE
ASK FOR ANOTHER SEPARATION
RELATED TO ITEM THREE I'M GOING
TO ASK FOR A MOTION TO
RECONSIDER ITEM THREE I AND J.
THAT IS GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
TO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD I
WOULD MOVE WE RECONSIDER THOSE
SIDES THANK YOU AND- I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR
LAYERED. THERE IS A MOTION
MADAM SECRETARY A MOTION TO
RECONSIDER CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION TO RECONSIDER GROVE HI.
I KAMLAGER. CAN I LAYERED HI
THERE I BATES ALL RIGHT I
ATKINS AYE AT THE SIDE I BE TO
TAKE A MOTION UNDER GOV. AT
GOVERNORS APPOINT. FOR THEIR
RESOURCE BOARD THREE I. OUR
MOTION THANK YOU CENTER GLARE A
MOST TO MOVE THREE HI MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE RIGHT GROUP I CAN.
KAMLAGER I. FIVE THEY HAVE
STATE EIGHT THING I THINK. FIVE
SO THAT PASSED THIS ZERO THANK
I ENTERTAIN AND ON ITEM J.
THEIR RESOURCES MS VIENNA ARE
WITH SOME THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED ON FLOOR MANAGER PLEASE
CALL TE ROLL. NO NOW HOW LONG
RIGHT AND LONGER HI YEARS I.
WHAT'S THE- AT I. THANK YOU
PASSES FOR THREE VOTES- ONE NO
ONE UPS THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT WE GO TO ITEM B. UNDER OF
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THE OF
CHAIRED. THOSE ARE A DIRECTOR
OF HIGH SCHOOL MAY INS IN THE
OF A AND- AT THE OF AND RE. I
MISS LOW LET ME TO REALLY THANK
YOU FOR AND TEN PATIENTS WHICH
I NOTE THAT YOU HAVE WITH US
THROUGHOUT HEARING. LET ME-
WELCOME YOU AND- ASK IF YOU'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE ANYONE WITH
YOU WELCOME THOSE INTRODUCTIONS
AND THEN MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE AND
AFTER THAT I'LL GO DIRECTLY TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON
PROTANDIM OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JERRY LOZANO AND I'M
BEFORE YOU TODAY AS YOU
DIRECTOR OF ICE'S ME EAST. FOR
THE APARTMENT AND REVIEW. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR GOING TO BE TO
THIS IN THIS ARE BIG TEAM FOR
THEIR INCOME IN THE. BEFORE THE-
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS OFF.
TO THE MY FAMILY MEMBERS
MENTORS IN FRIENDS WHO WATCHING
HEAR. MOST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
READ. IN PLAIN VIEW NUMBER MY
WIFE OF TWENTY FOUR YEAR. WHO
HAS BEEN MY- SOUNDING. I
THROUGHOUT THIS CAREER. WITHOUT
HER SUPPORT NOT. I WOULD NOT BE
CITY BEFORE YOU TODAY. I WOULD
ALSO TO THANK OUR DAUGHTER. WE
ARE JUST PROUD OF HER YOU KNOW
TRIPS. HER GRADUATION FROM THE
STUDENT. CHICO JUST LAST MONTH.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL TEAM AND A SIGN TO BETWEEN.
WITH ME JUST A COURT
INSTITUTIONS ARGUE THE BASE. I
BEGAN MY CAREER AS A PROUD
MEMBER. OF THE BASIC
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER ACADEMY
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN I PROMOTED
THROUGHOUT THE UNIFORMED
CUSTODY RANGE RESULTING IN THE
ASSIGNMENT. TO FIVE DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS SOME OF MY CAREER
HIGHLIGHTS INCLUDE BEING
ASSIGNED TO DO A VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION. TWICE DURING MY
CAREER AS BOTH A SERGEANT IN
THE CAPTAIN. WHERE I GAINED
VALUABLE SUPERVISORY AND
MANAGERIAL EXPERIENCE IN A
CORRECTIONAL CENTER. I SERVED
AS THE CHIEF DEPUTY WARDEN AT
FOLSOM STATE PRISON FOR MORE
THAN THREE YEARS OR HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH BOTH
MALE AND FEMALE INCARCERATED
PERSONS IN FINALLY I WAS
BLESSED AND HONORED TO WORK
WITH A DYNAMIC TEAM THAT
DEMONSTRATED EXCELLENT. WITHIN
ALL DISCIPLINES OF OUR
DEPARTMENT AND SHOWED ME THE
SUCCESSES OF COLLABORATION WHEN
I WAS APPOINTED AS THE WORKING
AT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITY. IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY I WAS APPOINTED TO MY
CURRENT ASSIGNMENT. WITHIN THE
HIGH SECURITY MISSION WE FOCUS
ON DAILY OPERATIONS WITHIN
PRISONS. SUPPORTING AND
EMPOWERING OUR LOCAL LEADERSHIP
TEAMS AND ENCOURAGING
COLLABORATION AMONGST PRISONS
WITHIN THE MISSION IN AN EFFORT
TO STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE
PROCESSES. I BELIEVE THE
LEADERS IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
MUST BE REGULAR VISITORS TO THE
INSTITUTIONS IN BEING SENSIBLE
TOM FOLEY'S INCLUDING THE
MANAGEMENT TEAM AS WELL AS OUR
INCARCERATED POPULATION. I'M
GETTING SHE DIDN'T PLAY WITH
HIGH STANDARDS TWO HUNDRED AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF LEADING BY
EXAMPLE AND ALWAYS GIVE MY BEST
EFFORT WHILE PERFORMING MY
DUTIES. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU DO ALL TODAY AND I AM NOT A
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE FOR ME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET ME ASK MISS US SENATOR
COM WONDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE THIS OFFICE TALK. THANK
YOU AT MADAM CHAIR MADAM PRO
TEM IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
SIR AND I THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME OUT OF YOUR SCHEDULE
EARLIER THIS WEEK- TO MEET WITH
ME- BEFORE TODAY- I KNOW WE-
TALKED ABOUT. A LOT OF THINGS
AND I DON'T HAVE THAT MANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT- I DO
HAVE A FEW AND THEY MOSTLY-
DEAL WITH HOW WE ARE TREATING-
PEOPLE- IN THE SYSTEM PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED. IN THE
SYSTEM AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING IN THE SYSTEM- AND LYFT
ASK THESE QUESTIONS WHEN WE
SPOKE SO I CERTAINLY- AS I
SHARED WITH YOU NOT INTERESTED
IN GOTCHA QUESTIONS- BUT WANTED
YOU TO KNOW WHERE I WAS COMING
FROM. I RECOGNIZE- AS YOU
STATED THAT YOU WERE NOT. THERE
IN THOSE PARTICULAR FACILITIES
AT THE TIME OF THE INCIDENTS.
BUT YOU WERE IN FACT- IN THE
SYSTEM. AND NOW WITH THIS
POSITION- IT WILL BE YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE THINGS DON'T HAPPEN
AGAIN- AND IT DEALS WITH YOU
KNOW HIGH SECURITY FACILITIES.
WHERE I ASSUME AND I THINK MOST
OF US ASSUME THAT THERE ARE
AMPLE CHECKS AND BALANCES- AND
THEN ADDITIONAL CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
PRISONS ARE SAFE. AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN THE
PRISONS THAT ARE SAFE. SO MY
FIRST QUESTION IS IF YOU- AND
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THESE THINGS DON'T
HAPPEN AGAIN. SO THE FIRST
EXAMPLE DEALS WITH THE SUICIDE
OF VALENTINO RODRIGUEZ WHO WAS-
AN EMPLOYEE AND WHO COMMITTED
SUICIDE AFTER REPEATED-
INCIDENTS OF HAZING AND
BULLYING AND INTIMIDATION.
WHERE HE HAD TAKEN A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE TO FOCUS ON HIS MENTAL
HEALTH- AND HAD BECOME HEALTHY
AGAIN AND THEN WENT BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM WHERE THESE THINGS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AND
ULTIMATELY HE TOOK HIS LIFE- WE
KNOW THAT THE LIFE EXPECTANCY
OF SOMEONE WHO WORKS IN ONE OF
OUR PRISONS AS FIVE YEARS AFTER
THEIR RETIREMENT. BECAUSE OF
SUICIDE WE KNOW ABOUT THE
UPTICK IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
ALCOHOLISM AND- ABUSE. BY FOLKS
WHO ARE WORKING IN THE PRISON.
AND SO WANT TO KNOW YOUR
pTHAT WE DO NOT HAVE. MORE MR
RODRIGUEZ IS. IN EMPLOYED ARM
BY OUR SYSTEM IN OUR PRISONS
BECAUSE I SUSPECT HIS FAMILY
NEVER THOUGHT THAT HE WOULD GO
TO WORK AT A PRISON TO KILL
HIMSELF BECAUSE OF THE BULLYING
THAT HE WAS HAVING TO INDOOR BY
HIS FELLOW EMPLOYEES. TWENTY
FIRST AND FOREMOST I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR HIM TO LEADERSHIP
OF OUR ORGANIZATION IN MYSELF
INCLUDED TO RECOGNIZE THAT I'M
EASE OUR- SERIOUS ISSUES. AND I
THINK GAS IS FAR IS TREATING
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE. WITH
RESPECT. EXPECTATIONS ON OUR
PROFESSIONAL WORK ENVIRONMENT
IS ALWAYS HALF HAS TO BE IN NOT
ONLY A PORTION ON HELD. ON AS
WELL IT IS ENCOURAGED. THANK
YOU COUNTY ONLY GOES A LONG WAY
WITH THAT. THE DEPARTMENT'S
NINE D. A LOT WITH THE HELP OF
THE LEGISLATURE- IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE LAST FOUR
FIVE YEARS ON EMPLOYEE WELLNESS
AND I THINK WE'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- I THINK- IS WE
SPOKE. EARLIER IN THE WEEK I
CAN'T SPECIFICALLY SPEAK ABOUT
THE CASE THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO AS IT'S CURRENTLY UNDER
INVESTIGATION. BY MY
EXPECTATION WOULD BE THAT THIS
INCIDENT IS. ARE INVESTIGATED
THOROUGHLY YEAH. WHERE WERE THE
RISKY. PART OR ANY INFORMATION
THAT CAN ASSIST US IN COMING TO
THE BEST INCLUSION AND ACCURATE
CONCLUSION OF AN INVESTIGATION
THE ACT- WE DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE HE- GREW UP TO FIND.
THANK YOU WELL I HOPE AFTER THE
INCIDENT HAS BEEN INVESTIGATED
THOROUGHLY THAT THERE'S ALSO
VERY THOROUGH AND HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT CHANGING THE
CULTURE IN THE PRISON. AND THE
SECOND QUESTION RELATED TO HOW
WE TREAT PEOPLE HAS TO DO WITH
THE DEATH OF MISTER LUIS
ROMERO- AND WHO WAS-
DECAPITATED IN HIS CELL. HE WAS
PUT INTO A CELL WITH SOMEONE
WHO. WAS- HAD BEEN IN
PSYCHIATRIC WARDS ARM WAS HAD A
TRAUMATIZED A PRIOR STALEMATE.
AND HAD BEEN CATEGORIZED AS
BEING PRESIDENT'S AN ALLIANCE.
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS LAID UP IN
THE SALE DATE WITHOUT A HEAD
BECAUSE OF SOME EIGHT. ORDER
THEM. SO. I MEAN AND THIS MAN
WAS SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED ON
PAROLE I THINK IN A YEAR SO.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN I MEAN YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT FOLKS
HAVE TO- ARM. BE SENTENCED AND
SERVED A TIME FOR A CRIME
COMMITTED. BUT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING PEOPLE IN PRISON TO BE
TORTURED TO DEATH BY FOLKS WHO
SHOULD NOT HAVE A CELL MATE
WHEN IT IS KNOWN THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE A CELL MATE-
AND SO THEIR SAFETY. THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO BE. ADHERING TO
BOTH FOR. EMPLOYEES AND ALSO
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE. IN THE
PRESENCE SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
AND- QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU LET SOMEBODY IN A CELL
WITH SOMEBODY. WHO HAS THAT
KIND OF HISTORY THAT IS KNOWN.
UNLESS THERE'S JUST DISREGARD
FOR THE LIFE OF THE FOLKS WHO
WERE THERE. YES THEY DO SENATOR
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I'LL
POINT OUT THAT. I AS WE SPOKE
EARLIER- REGARDING THE ARE YOU
PLEASE THEIR WORK ENVIRONMENT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US AS
WELL AS THE INCARCERATED
PERSONS WITHIN OUR FACILITIES.
ON THEIR- SAFETY. IS IMPORTANT
TO US ARE. IT'S WELL KNOWN
PEOPLE NEED TO FEEL SAFE IN
ORDER TO REHABILITATE
THEMSELVES INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
OUR GOAL OF CREATING A BETTER.
YOU CAN BE IN A WIN HERE SHE
HAS RELEASED TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND I THINK THAT ACCOMPLISHES
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY I THINK
CHANGING CULTURE INSTITUTIONS
OUR ISSUES ARE VERY DYNAMIC I
KNOW WHEN I STARTED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES. R. S. I NG
YOU LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND OF
MY HISTORY AND MY EXPERIENCE IN
THIS DEPARTMENT. A DIFFERENT
THE ONE THEY WANT WANTED IS TO
GET. IN IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
ASKING HOW DO YOU KNOW- I BACK
LOOKS IT WHEN I WAS WHEN I
STARTED THIS DEPARTMENT IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WE WERE
WAREHOUSE IN ON THE FIRST
READING PEOPLE WE WORK REALLY
PROGRAM THE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO WEREN'T GIVEN ONE
OPPORTUNITY FOR REHABILITATION.
ARE WE HAVING THE ABILITY
SHOULD OR EVEN I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT THING AND IT
DOESN'T GO- UNAPPRECIATED BY
OUR DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP IN A
VAST MAJORITY. OF OUR EMPLOYEES
I THINK. I'M A COUPLE OF THE-
THAT WE DO CHIU INSURED THOSE
TYPES OF. OUR WE NEED TO GET
THE POSSIBILITY OF THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS HAPPEN AGAIN I THINK
IT COUNT ABILITY INSTRUCT FROM
THE TOP DOWN START WITH UNITED
SECURITY MISSION- THROUGH THE
WARRANTY STAND MANAGEMENT TEAMS
ALL THE WAY DOWN- THROUGHOUT
OUR ORGANIZATION. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A STEPS
AND WE DO HAVE STEPS IN PLACE
THE WORDS YOU. ARE MANAGED THE
OPERATIONS OF THE PRISON BE A
MONTHLY. REPORTS THAT WE REVIEW
CONCEPT REPORTS USE OF FORCE
REPORTS DIFFERENT.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY. ISSUES ARE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WOULD BE- FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE ALL OUR-
MONTHLY BUDGET REPORT AND THAT
WE REFORM JEWS OUT FOR ALL OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS TALKS ABOUT
RIDERSHIP DEFICIT. IN THINGS
LIKE THAT. THE OTHER AND ON THE-
LATER ON SHE IMPORTANT STYLE
CHANGING IS TO BE THERE- SHOULD
BE A VISITOR ARE HONORING BASIS
AND VIEWS- SORRY. ARCHING
DOUBLE CHECK BE A SITUATION AND
LYFT. ARE THE INCARCERATED
PERSONS ARE NOBODY ARMENIA WHO
I MANAGEMENT TEAM AND WE TALK
ABOUT SUCCESSION PLANNING GOALS
AND I SIT DOWN WITH ALL OF OUR
MANAGERS- I SPEAK IN TALK ABOUT
SUCCESSION PLANNING IN THEIR
DIRECTION AND CHALLENGE THEM
OUR CHIEF CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE
THEIR OWN PROCESSES TO INCLUDE
AT TO TRY TO GET BETTER. THE
OTHER THING IS I WALK ON THE
HOUSING MARKET THAT
RECREATIONAL FACILITIES. I AM
GOING TO. COLLEGE COURSE TAUGHT
ABOUT- ARE. YOU PRO THAT WE
GOING ON AT THE- R. ONE JUST
YOUR I AT OUR CALIFORNIA PRISON
HE ASKED. I GO TO THERE ARE I
SPEAK WITH THE AND- ADVICE
COMMITTEES ON THOSE ON WAS YOUR-
AND I ASK I. THE JUDGE. BACK
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED. FOR
YEARS EVEN BEFORE I STARTED
THIS DEPARTMENT ASKING WHAT
THEIR THOUGHTS ARE ON ON THE
CULTURE AND I THINK WE ALL CAN
DO TO PREVENT THAT WE'RE A LOT
BETTER THAN WE WERE WHEN I
STARTED THIS DEPARTMENT. WE'RE
NOT WHERE WE WANT TO BE IN
ORDER TO GET YOU STRIVE AND
WORK HARD AND WORK TOGETHER IN
COLLABORATION. WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INTERNAL. AND
EXTERNAL IN ORDER TO REACH OUR
GOALS. THANK YOU YOUR HAVE TO
THANK FOR- THAT RESPONSE- AND
JUST ALSO SAY THAT. THAT WAS
NOT AN ANSWER TO THE QUESTION-
MY QUESTION IS ABOUT IF SOMEONE
MR ROMERO DIDN'T NEED. A CHECK
IN ABOUT A COLLEGE COURSE HE
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE HE WASN'T
IN A CELL AT THE CITE NEST. WHO
CUT HIS HEAD OFF. AND PULLED
ENTRAILS OUT AND USE IT AS A
NECKLACE- AND IT GOES TO SAFETY.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I THINK LAST
YEAR I VOTED AYE ON SENATOR
WIENER'S BILL THE TRANSGENDER
RESPECT AGENCY INDIGNITY AFTER
ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID DURING
THAT HEARING IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT OUR PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THERE ARE SAFE. SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT MR ROMERO IN THE
NEXT MISTER ROMERO IS SAFE.
EVEN IF THEY'RE LOCKED UP FOR A
CRIME BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
TORTURED. AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR TRANSGENDER
POPULATION IS SAFE. AND IF WE
ARE NOT TAKING THE NECESSARY
PRECAUTIONS FOR FOLKS. THAT
MIGHT NOT SHARE OR REVEAL OR
MAY SHARE AND REVEAL A SPECIAL
CLASSIFICATION OR
DECLASSIFICATION AROUND THEIR
IDENTITY. THEN HOW DO I HAVE
ANY CONFIDENCE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE. KEEPING OUR TRANSGENDER
FOLKS SAFE WHO DO COME AND SAY
THIS IS HOW I IDENTIFY AND
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF-
PROGRAMMING AND ELEMENTS OF
SAFETY THAT I NEED IN ORDER TO
BE SAFE IN HERE WHILE AYE SIR
ABOUT MY TIME. SO LIKE THAT'S
THE QUESTION. I KNOW WE NEED
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY BUT- WE
ALSO HAVE TO HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LAKE THE
DISREGARD OR THE OR THE GROSS
EGREGIOUS MISTAKES THAT HAPPEN
THAT ACTUALLY COST PEOPLE'S
LIVES. YES I WOULD THANK YOU
SENATOR RIGHT I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
VIOLATION OF POLICY. I IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ELEMENT TO
SEE IN OUR IN OUR PRISONS I
ALSO- TREATY WITH OUR ARMED
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE IN
ALL OF OUR PLEASE REFER
NONPARTISAN EXTREMELY.
IMPORTANT ONES I ALSO- WOULD
SAY THAT EXCESS ABILITY TO
SUPERVISORS AND SHE ENSURING
OUR SUPERVISORS ARE OUT WALKING
AND TALKING TO BE A RESOURCE TO
OUR EMPLOYEES IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AS I SAID EARLIER-
IT'S EXTREMELY TRAGIC SITUATION
IT DOES NOT- IF IT ABSOLUTELY
MATTERS TO SHOULD BE- IN WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO DO EVERYTHING
SHE HAD. ARM CHIU INSURER- ON
SOMETHING LIKE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN UNION MITIGATE THAT- IF
SUPPORTERS ARE OUR DREAMS
JUNIOR- WE MAYBE I'D GET ON THE
COURSE READING IT. THAT. PRISON
SYSTEM WE- ALREADY TO. I IN
ACTING ASKING OUR THIRTY CHIU
AND THAT OR MEETING I HARD TO
BE THE EXPECTED OF ALLEGES. IN
A PARTLY B. AND- IMAGE PARTNER
IN THAT YOU YOU KNOW WE- THIS
LEGISLATURE ABOUT SAFETY ABOUT
ONE OF THE THINGS HE JUST SPOKE
ABOUT ABOUT RESEARCH POLICY ARE
YOU SOPRANOS ARE TREATING FOR.
EMPLOYEES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
KNOW THE IMPACT ON HOW PROGRAMS
AFFECTING GROCERY PERSONS ON
VETERAN JUNIOR OR IDENTIFIES
TRENDS YEARS. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT WERE ON OUR WAY- ON
WHAT I THINK WELL I'M I'M
EXTREMELY HAPPY WITH WHERE
WE'VE GONE WITH SB ONE THIRTY
TWO SO FAR WE'RE NOT WHERE WE
NEED TO BE BUT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD TO GET
WHERE- MORE. FULLY IMPLEMENTED
INTO. SHE MILLION FOUR HAPPY
WITH. THE AMPLE OF ALLEGED.
THANK YOU- I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
THAT WHEN WE TALKED AND I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE- AN INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS SUCCESSFUL AND I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS I. SHARED WITH
YOU IS THAT IT'S NOT. IT'S AS
MUCH ABOUT WHAT WE CALL PEOPLE
AS IT IS HOW WE TREAT PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DOING AND WITH ALL OF OUR
SYSTEM. I KNOW THAT YOU MENTION
THAT THERE ARE. A LOT OF SMALL
SUCCESSES THAT ARE HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE PRISON SYSTEM-
AND WE SORT OF TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF MAKING THOSE.
SUCCESSES AND THOSE PROGRAMS
SCALABLE- AND WAYS IN WHICH TO
BRING CONSISTENCY WITH THE
PROGRAMMING. ACROSS THE
MULTIPLE PRISONS- THAT WE
OPERATE. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I CERTAINLY NEVER
WANT TO BE SEEN AS LIKE YOU
KNOW. AN APOCALYPTIC MEMBER
HALLWAYS TALKING ABOUT BAD
STUFF WITH CDC ARE BUT- I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO ELEVATE
THESE KINDS OF THINGS SO THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT SOMEONE IS
WATCHING. AND THAT SOMEONE
CARES ABOUT THESE PEOPLE- AND I
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU HAVE A
TALL TASK IN FRONT OF YOU- AND
AHEAD OF YOU- AND MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST SORT OF.
USING THESE POSITIONS AS DJANGO
POSITIONS AND HAVING PEOPLE GO
FROM ONE SIDE ONE SLOT TO
ANOTHER. WITHOUT REALLY
INVESTING IN THE KIND OF
CULTURE CHANGE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE THAT IS REQUIRED TO MAKE
CDC ARE SUCCESSFUL SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THAT YOU
SPENT WITH ME. AND FOR YOUR
TIME ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS
AGAIN TODAY. YOU CENTER THANK
YOU. SENATOR GROVE. M. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEMP I- I'M GONNA
FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THAT MY COLLEAGUE AND
IN LOS ANGELES A FROM LOS
ANGELES ASKED BECAUSE I STILL
DON'T- I DON'T FEEL SATISFIED
WITH THE RESPONSES AND I DON'T
MEAN TO BE RUDE OR- MEANING I
JUST AM LOOKING FOR A SPECIFIC
RESPONSE. YOU KNOW AS THE
MURDER WHICH PUT THIS CHANNEL
THIS INDIVIDUAL IN PRISON FOR
THEIR FOR HIS LIFE- ACTUALLY
TOOK PLACE IN KERN COUNTY- GIVE
IT PENNER WAS THIRTY SIX YEARS
OLD SHE WAS A MOTHER OF SIX WAS
DOWN OR LACK HE'S LIVING IN A
HOTEL AND SHE RUNS INTO THIS
INDIVIDUAL I'M NOT GONNA SAY
HIS NAME BECAUSE I AM NOT
GIVING IN MANY. NO RECOGNITION
WHATSOEVER- KIDDING NO SYMPATHY
HE SAID HE DIDN'T THAT HE SAID
THAT HE- IS A **** AND THAT- HE
SADISTIC AND THAT HE WOULD DO
IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN- IN THIS
YOUNG WOMAN THIS YOUNG MOM LOST
HER LIFE- THE SISTER THE
STARTER- IT ROCKED OUR
COMMUNITY. AND- SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT WASN'T ANSWERED
THAT I WOULD LIKE A SPECIFIC
ANSWER TO IS. WHY DID HE HAVE A
CELL MATE. DID YOU SENATOR ON
FOR THE QUESTION AREN'T IN A
BELIEVE SHE'S SPECIFIC INCIDENT
I BELIEVE WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
LITIGATION. ON ON THIS INCIDENT
SO. I'M NOT SURE THAT I CAN
SPEAK ABOUT HIS SPECIFIC.
INCIDENT BY- OKAY GENERALLY
GENERALLY WHY WOULD YOU PUT A
SELDOM US GIVE A SADISTIC. TIME
AND TIME AGAIN KILLER. THE
ADMITS THAT HE HAS AN ISSUE THE
SADISTIC THAT HE'S A SATANIST
AND HE ARE ACTUALLY I DON'T SEE
ENJOYS IT BUT HE ACTUALLY. SAYS
HE'LL DO IT OVER AND OVER WHY
WOULD SOMEONE LIKE THAT HAVE A
CELL MATE SENATOR LET ME- I
THINK I HAVE A WAY TO FRAME
THIS QUESTION THAT I WOULD LIKE
A RESPONSE TO IN WRITING THANK
YOU I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
AND YOU MAY HAVE TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER. MISTER LOZANO BUT WE
WILL EXPECT IT BEFORE- BEFORE
THE FLOOR VOTE WHICH IS. A
WRITTEN RESPONSE TO WHAT
FACTORS ARE CONSIDERED THAT
COULD LEAD TO A VIOLENT
MENTALLY ILL OFFENDER BEING
DOUBLE CELLED I THINK IF THERE
ARE POLICIES ARE OR DIRECTION
WITHIN CDC ARE THAT COULD
RESPOND TO THAT WE WOULD TRULY
LIKE TO SEE IT BECAUSE IF THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT. BUT THERE
ARE CLEAR GUIDELINES ON OR OR
SOME INFORMATION THAT WE COULD
HAVE ACCESS TO AND THAT MAY BE
SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE TAKES
UP AT SOME POINT. ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF AND REALLY WITH
RESPECT YOUR JOB IS INCREDIBLY
HARD. I AND THERE'S NO WAY MOST
OF US COULD EVEN REMOTELY
UNDERSTAND- THE KIND OF
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT I DO
BELIEVE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AND WITH THE
PRISON POPULATION DECLINING. IN
PARTICULAR I THINK THE IN LIGHT
OF THAT- WE WOULD LIKE TO GET A
WRITTEN RESPONSE ON THE
FACTORS- SO THAT WE CAN
DETERMINE- YOU KNOW IF WE THINK
IS A LEGISLATURE THERE ARE
THINGS WE CAN DO TO BE HELPFUL
TO YOU- SO THAT THAT'S TAKEN
OFF OF YOUR PLATE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO. MAKE PERSONAL
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS AROUND IT
IS THERE MAYBE POLICIES THAT
APPLY BUT I'LL MAKE SURE YOU
GET THAT QUESTION IN WRITING SO
THAT IT IS- IT'S CLEAR WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR AND I DON'T
KNOW SENATOR I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT BUT IF THAT COULD BE
HELPFUL I THINK ALL OF US WOULD
LIKE THAT OTHERWISE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THREE MORE
QUESTIONS. THAT IS THAT ARE THE
SAME AND I THINK I THINK WE DO
EXPECT RESPONSE BUT IF THAT'S
HELPFUL I APPRECIATE THE PRO
TEMPS- INTERFERENCE ON THAT IN
A MORE PROFESSIONAL WAY TO.
RESPOND TO THIS- I'D LIKE MY
GIRL YOU KNOW HERE I DID HIGH I
AM NOT MAKING A STATEMENT ABOUT
A PERFECT I JUST. I PUT IT IN I
PUT IT IN WRITING IN THAT WAY
SO THAT WE GET A RESPONSE THAT
WE- HAVE RECEIVED YOUR AND HOW
TO USE IT THE WAY YOU ASK THE
QUESTION IS THE WAVE MOST
PEOPLE GENERALLY PROBABLY NOT
NO I THINK ANOTHER WAY TO SAY
TO SENATOR GROWTH LEADS TO PRO
TEM FOLLOWERS- PLEASE. OKAY NOT
EVEN NICE TO FORGIVE US. FOR WE
HAVE OUR OWN BRAND OF DIFF.
HERE SENATOR GROWTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR QUESTION THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM I WOULD ALSO
LIKE IN THAT LETTER IF
POSSIBLE. THE LIKE HOW OFTEN TO
GUARDS GO BY A SALES LIKE
WHAT'S THAT CHECKED TIME
WARNER. METER PEOPLE CHECKED
EVERY TWO HOURS FOUR HOURS SIX
HOURS EIGHT HOURS. SO WE COULD
ABSOLUTELY- ADDED TO THE
ANSWERS THAT I PROVIDE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE IN WRITING. A
GENERAL FOR OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION- IN THE CENTER IN
OREGON HISTORY OF SEGREGATION
UNITS- IS THERE WHICH CHECKED
ON TWICE AN HOUR- NO MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES APART.
TWICE AN HOUR NO MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES APART HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE TO DECAPITATE
SOMEBODY WITH THE SHIP. I'M
SORRY CENTER I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT QUESTION NINETY I DON'T
KNOW. OKAY M. I WOULD THINK IT
WOULD TAKE AN EXTREMELY LONG
TIME AND- ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT
THE DESCRIPTION OF THE WEAPON
WAS ALL- I WOULD THINK THAT
BASED ON THE INFORMATION I READ
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL WAS- THE
INDIVIDUAL MUST REMEMBER WAS
ALIVE- FOR AT LEAST PART OF
THIS TORTURE THAT TOOK PLACE
AND I WOULD THINK THAT IF- IS
CDCR STAFF. WALKED BY THE CELL
EVERY THIRTY FIVE MINUTES.
THERE WOULD BE SOME TYPE OF. I
DON'T KNOW BLOOD WHATEVER YEAH.
THEY WOULD EVEN THINK. ANYWAY
SO OKAY I'LL SKIP THAT SUBJECT
MATTER- I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT
I THAT YOU KNOW THEM. I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE HARDEST JOBS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
TO DEAL WITH A PRISON INMATE
POPULATION. I'M ARGUE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES AND
I THINK THEY SHOULD ALL BE
SAFE. AND IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
I REALIZE THERE ARE MANY
POLICIES THAT ARE PASSED OUT OF
THIS BUILDING THAT DON'T ALLOW
YOU TO HAVE SOME TYPE- YOU KNOW
THE MAJORITY OF AUTHORITATIVE
CONTROL I HAVE. HEARD STORIES
FROM SOME OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES WITH A LARGE
PRISON POPULATION IN OUR AND MY
COMMUNITY AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER
NICE FACT MY COLLEAGUES. CAN
TAKE DOWN. WE HAVE MORE PRISONS
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY I AM. I
F. I DO I DO UNDERSTAND AND DO
KNOW THAT THE WORK THAT CDC ARE.
OFFICERS DO THE G. YOU GUYS I
FEEL SOMETIMES ARE LIKE IN WAY
OVER YOUR HEAD YOU'RE NOT ARMED
AS THEY THROW FECES I KNEW THEY
SPEND ON YOU THEY THROW URINE
ON YOU SO YOU'RE EXPOSED TO YOU
KNOW AT EITHER SUBJECT TO
TRANSMIT A LIVE TRANSMISSION OF
DISEASES- YOU KNOW TRANSPORTING
INMATES FROM ONE PLACE TO THE
OTHER AND YOU KNOW THE LEFT OF
OUR COUNTRY OR THE LEFT OF OUR
STATE WANTS TO. YOU KNOW TO GET
YOU KNOW GIVEN I DON'T KNOW
GARDENING TOOLS TO HAVE A
GARDEN AND IT'S LIKE THEY'D
KILL EACH OTHER MOST A LOT OF
MONEY LIKE THIS INDIVIDUAL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY I
WOULD NEVER GIVE HIM A
GARDENING TOOL AND SO. I DO I
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT ALL
OF YOU DO I REALLY REALLY DO I
KNOW IT'S A VERY VERY HARD JOB
I JUST THINK THAT WHEN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS HAPPEN AND
IT THAT CASTING A HUGE DOUBT ON
THE ABILITY TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
AND SO- S. THANK YOU FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO LET ME AND GO ON TO
A DIFFERENT SUBJECT. CONTRA
BRAND I ACTUALLY GOT TO GO TO
KERN COUNTY PRISON I WENT TO
PELICAN BAY AND I WENT TO A
COUPLE OF OTHER PRISONS TO A
TOUR THESE PRISONS- WHEN WE
WERE STARTING TO ADDRESS THE-
THIS THAT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION- WANTED TO
RELEASE PRISONERS AND SO I KIND
OF WANTED TO. YOU KNOW CHECK IT
OUT MYSELF I GUESS AND THEN- I
ALSO WAS VERY CURIOUS ABOUT THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS THAT ARE SYNCED TO LIFE IN
PRISON. OR THE YOUNGER THAN
EIGHTEEN AND THEN THEY DON'T
HAVE A POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE
AND YOU HAVE THESE YOUNG KIDS
WITH NO HOPE THAT. HAVE NEVER
EVER NEVER GOING TO SEE THE
OUTSIDE OF YOU KNOW FOR SOME
STUPID RIFIC THING THAT THEY
DID. M. ON THAT SUBJECT MATTER.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW YOUR OPINION
IF YOU DO HAVE A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD THAT COMMITS M. LISC MURDER
LIST NAME A CRIME AND THEIR
SENTENCE TO LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE IF THEY
COMMITTED THAT SAME PRIME WHEN
THEY WERE EIGHTEEN. THEY WOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO FOR
PAROLE BOARD AFTER SEVEN YEARS-
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SOMEBODY AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THIS SATANIC PERSON AND I
DON'T EVER WANT ANYBODY LIKE
THAT INCLUDED IN THIS.
EQUITATION BUT WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHT OF SOMEBODY NEVER EVER
EVER BEING ABLE TO GET OUT OF
PRISON IF DOES IT CREATE MORE
AT THAT. A PROBLEM CHILD IN
PRISON YOU KNOW LIKE MORE OF A
RISK OR IF THEY HAVE HOPE AND
THEY KNOW IT FOR ON GOOD
BEHAVIOR FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
GO THROUGH PAROLE BOARD.
APPROVAL HEARING AND YOU KNOW
RE POSITION FOR RESET AND
SEIGNER WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE DO YOU THINK THAT THAT
CREATES A MORE MODEL PRISONER.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE. SO IN MY
EXPERIENCE- I USE- BEEN A
LEADERSHIP ROLES AT AT FIVE
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS AND I
ABSOLUTELY THINK THAT OUR WHOLE
WITHIN OUR COUNTRY POPULATIONS
ARE IT IS IMPORTANT IT'S
IMPORTANT NOT JUST FOR THE
LOCATION A BETTER- OP PROGRAM
THE- OR- I PERSONALLY
PERSONALLY BUT ALSO SAFER WORK
ENVIRONMENTS OUR STAFF. SO I
ALWAYS THINK HAVING LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL HOPE THAT
IT WOULD BE THAT THEY CAN WORK
THEIR WAY IN ON YOUR WAY- TO
SHOW UP FOR WORK THAT DAY TO BE
RELEASED BACK INTO OUR SOCIETY
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THE IN
DEPTH PROVIDES A SAFER.
OPPORTUNITY IN THE MARKET FOR A
PLEASED TO WORK I PERSONALLY
ARE RECOMMENDED- BECAUSE RATED
PEOPLE THAT I SHOWS US STEPS
OF REHABILITATION FOR ELEVEN
MORE SECRETARY FOR
CONSIDERATION. I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT OUR LOCAL
ARMENIAN JEWS USE IN
INSTITUTIONS ROCK THE STATE ON
A REGULAR BASIS AND ABSOLUTELY
I HOPE IT YEAH COMMITTEE HOPE
TORRENT PERSONALLY POPULATION
PROVIDES SAFER. OUR WORK
ENVIRONMENT FOR EMPLOYEES IN A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY IN WAR
FOCUSED IMPORTANCE ON
REHABILITATION FROM ARCONIC.
INCARCERATED POPULATION. THE
YOU. AND YOUR FOR GOT ELECT ON
LIKE YOU A CRIME YOU DO THE-
IT'S LIKE I'M ON THE WITH THAT
I HAD NO. ADJUSTMENT PERIOD
LIKE LIKE I DIDN'T FROM AT ALL.
THEN I MET SOMEBODY THAT- HAD
ME SPEAK TO- SOME YOUNG KIDS
AND THEY REALLY TOUCH MY HEART
AND YOU KNOW I THOUGHT
REDEMPTION COULD POSSIBLY BE
POSSIBLE FOR SOME OF THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS AND EVEN ADULTS I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW M. F. PERFECT
CASE EXAMPLE- I WHEN I WENT TO
VISIT ONE OF THE PRISONS. YOU
KNOW YOU TO TREAT PEOPLE LIKE
THEY'RE NOT EVERYDAY PEOPLE
RIGHT I'M SHAKING PEOPLE'S
HANDS HIGH SENATOR GROVE IN.
THE HOPE THAT WORDING LIKE
GRABS MY ARM LIKE IS GONNA SOLD
ME AND HE SAYS DON'T TELL THEM
WHO YOU ARE DON'T TOUCH HIM.
LIKE OKAY. AND THEN WE WENT
INTO A CLASSROOM TYPE SETTING
AND THERE WAS AN EMPTY SEAT
LIKE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ROOM
SO I JUST WALKED IN AND SAT
DOWN AT THE EMPTY SEAT MAJORITY
SAID IAN AND THE GUY WAS KINDA
HIDING A STAFFING. AND I SAID
THAT WHAT IS IT HE KEPT HIDING
IT TWICE TO GET FROM HIM. AND
HE'S I LOOKED AT IT AND THEY
WERE WORDS LIKE CAL AND- THEY
THEY WAS DEFINITELY ON A COW
WAS ON IT. BECAUSE IF I PASS
THIS TEST TODAY I GET. TO MOVE
ON TO A HIGHER GRADE LEVEL. AND
I SAID I CAN YOU'LL DO. REALLY
AND HE GOES WELL TRUTHFULLY I
HAVE TROUBLE BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD BE SPELLED P. AJ. SO I
YOU KNOW MY HEART HAS OPENED UP
TO A POPULATION THAT AND- THIS
IS TWO THOUSAND TEN WHEN I
FIRST GOT HERE I DON'T WANT
THEM COMPLETELY DISCARDED NOW
WE'RE NOT AGAIN WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT. THE WHACK JOB
THAT COMMITTED A HORRIFIC
MURDER SEVERAL TIMES AND
DECAPITATED CELLMATE- BUT I
THINK THERE IS I WAS CURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
HAVING PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE
HOPE TO GET OUT EVEN IF THEY'RE
SIXTY YEARS OLD HAVE HOPE.
FIFTY FIVE YEARS OLD WHATEVER
TO GET OUT AND HAVE. A HOPE TO
IF IT CREATED A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT. ONE OF THE THINGS
I SAW- AFTER WE LEFT THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND- YOU
KNOW ALL OF THAT IN THE YARD WE
WENT INTO THE FORENSIC CRAM.
AND I WAS. SHOP IS THE BEST WAY
I CAN PUT IT OF THE
COMMUNICATION SKILLS THAT
PRISONERS HAVE. NOTE YOU KNOW
FULL THAT IS TINY AS A- ARE YOU
KNOW JUST IT'S LIKE I CAN YOU
BELIEVE IS NOTE AND THEN WHEN
THEY TOOK THE LITTLE- TWEEZERS
AND THEY AND FULL THAT THAT
NOTE IT WAS A YOU KNOW. TWENTY
PARAGRAPH. THE AND IT DID LOOK
LIKE IT COULD FIT UNDER A
FINGERNAIL. THE MATTER FACT
THAT'S HOW THEY GOT THERE IS A
VENDOR FINGERNAIL. AND ALSO
CELL PHONES RADIOS HOW DID THEY
GET THOSE THINGS IN PRISON.
SHOW NO CHEATING IN GENERAL ARE
USUALLY HAND WRITTEN ON BY OUR
HI GROCERY GET POPULATION TO
COMMUNICATE WITH ONE ANOTHER-
THE CELL PHONES AND RADIOS-
CELLPHONES ARE OBVIOUSLY. A
CONTRABAND ITEM IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM- THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED. IN
SO THOSE ARMS. ARE RUNNING
ILLEGALLY WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH- DROPS TO SUPPLY
ENGINES THAT. ARE BRINGING
SUPPLIES FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
SECURE WALLS INTO THE INSIDE-
VISITORS EMPLOYEES. MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS. TRYING TO COMBAT DAY
INTRODUCTION. OF CONTRABAND. SO
WHAT DO YOU DOING TO THE SO
THEY IT KEEPS OUR AND OUR
OFFICER SAFE. ENTER INMATES BUT
OFFICERS. YES ON A DAILY BASIS
AT ALL OF THE INSTITUTIONS WE
HAVE ON OUR UNIT AN
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES UNIT
KNACK IS WORKING HARD TO COMBAT
THE INTRODUCTION OF CONTRABAND
ON WORKING CHOOSE- JUST LIKE
FOR COMMUNICATION BETWEEN- I.
IT WAS REALLY POPULAR HE S. T.
ARE SO JUST EVERY DAY CONTROLS
ARE WE DO CELL SEARCHES DO YOU-
CLOVER BODY STURGEONS DO YOU.
BURKE CHIU OUR UNCLOTHED BODY
SEARCHES D. CONTROLLERS FANS
LINES. THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS WE REVIEW AND ARE LOOKING
CHIU AND NAY ALL IN OF COURSE
LISTEN TO OUR PHONE CALLS
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
WE YOU COULD GIVE ME THREE
THINGS THAT WE AT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DO. TO HELP
YOU KEEP- INMATES SAFE AND MORE
I WAS THE MOST WIDELY BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE OFFICERS THAT-
WORK IN THESE THESE FACILITY
SAFE. I WHAT WOULD THEY BE.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SENATOR
THANK YOU- I WOULD SAY ACTION
TEAM TO SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY.
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT OUR THE
MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT IAN.
REHABILITATION AND- I THINK
DOES PROVIDE. THE FOR WORKING
ACTUALLY TECHNOLOGY SOME OF THE
ITEMS THAT WE ARE USING TODAY
WE DIDN'T HAVE TEN YEARS AGO TO
HELP US WITH CELL PHONES- DOES.
HE IS THE EVER EVOLVING
ARAMBULA. INCLUSION OF
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION ERRORS
OUT WE GET UP I. ONE OF OUR
HIGH SECURITY PRISONS IAN JOB
SO THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
BAGGAGE SCANNER STUFF LIKE THAT
ALWAYS ASSIST IN APPREHENDING
CONTRIBUTE. OKAY THANK YOU AND
I DO I DO APPLAUD YOU GUYS I
MEAN THAT I EVEN WENT TO THE
ISSUE AND THE THAT'S PRETTY
SCARY MORE- I KNOW THAT PEOPLE
SAY OH THEY KEEP HIM IN DOG
CAGES ARE DOG KENNELS OR THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT- AND- THOSE ARE
PRETTY SCARY PEOPLE- IN THOSE
TEN BY TEN- CAGES I GUESS YOU
WOULD SAY I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE CALLED-
WE- WE HAVE BY. THE PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES WITHIN OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION
UNITS HAPPENS WITHIN SMALL
MANAGED ARTS SMALL MANAGE ME
ARTS OKAY YES AND YES SO AND
WHEN WE WALKED BY THERE IT
ALWAYS SAID I WAS REALLY
THANKFUL THERE WAS SAID
CHAINLINK AND A BRICK WALL
BETWEEN US ARE YOU KNOW THAT
WAS HLFWAY UP SO I WAS
THANKFUL FOR THAT SO- ANYWAYS
THANK YOU- AGAIN JUST LIKE THE
PREVIOUS- ET DE MIS. LEVINE HI
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE TAKING
THIS JOB- BUT I'M GLAD THAT YOU
ARE AND I HOPE YOU WORK
DILIGENTLY TO KEEP OUR OFFICERS
SAFE. AND SEND THEM HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES EVERY NIGHT AND
I HOPE THAT- ALIGNED WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
COMMENTS THAT. YOU KNOW AND IF
YOU'RE CONVICTED OF A CRIME IN
YOUR SERVING IN A IN A PRISON
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
SHOULD AND SERVE YOUR TIME. YOU
SHOULD TRY YOUR THING HERE TO
GET REHABILITATED TO BE A
BETTER SOME MEMBER SOCIETY WHEN
YOU GET OUT- BUT YOU SHOULD
ALSO HAVE- SOME TYPE OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM THAT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DECAPITATED OR MURDERED OR
STABBED HER FEET AT FOR.
WHATEVER TAKES PLACE. WHATEVER
ELSE TAKES PLACE IN PRISON
SYSTEM. SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU SENATOR ROVE MEADOW VICE
CHAIR. FOR THANK YOU THE
MEMBERS HERE AND- SKEWS ME MR
LEVINE- I SAY GOD BLESS YOU I'M
LOOKING AT YOUR RESUME AND YOU
BEEN DOING THIS FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS AND- EVEN GRADUATED UP
WHICH IS REALLY INCREDIBLE TO.
THE HIGH SECURITY PRISONS WHERE
YOU HAVE PROBABLY OF THOSE WHO
ARE. ON A SCALE OF ONE TO TEN
THEIR TAN IN TERMS OF THEIR
DANGER- TO THEMSELVES AND
CERTAINLY TO OTHERS SO- WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND CERTAINLY I
YOU WOULDN'T BE DOING IT
WITHOUT IT COME. OF SUPER
COMMITMENT. TO WHAT IS NOW AN
APPROACH OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WHICH I AM VERY HIGH ON. AS A
MEMBER OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I DID HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT OUR
DEALS WE HAVE THE MORE SERIOUS
IT'S PROBABLY TO WHAT. YOU
MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH JAMES
MUSIC FACILITY IN IRVINE IT'S
CALLED THE FARMS. THAT THAT'S
WHERE A LOT OF THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAM STARTED
IN PILOT STARTED I DO SEE HOW
THOSE ARE WORKING. AND YOU'VE
BEEN AND LOOKING OUT TO THE
LENGTH OF TIME THAT YOU HAVE
SERVED. YOU PROBABLY HAVE A
GOOD PERSPECTIVE ON WHETHER
THIS APPROACH TO REHABILITATE.
IS DOING THE JOB- AS WE SEE SO
MANY BEING RELEASED- FOR. GOOD
CREDIT GOOD CONDUCT HI AND I'D
LIKE TO GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT I IF I'D HAD TIME TO HAVE
YOU IN MY OFFICE WE WOULD HAVE
A MORE IN DEPTH DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PUT ON THE RECORD
THAT DIFFER OF THE EVOLUTION
REALLY. OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE IT STILL
HAS ITS ISSUES AND IT'S
PROBLEMS. THE DARK SIDE I WOULD
SAY. IT SEEMS TO ME THERE'S A
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
WHERE WE ARE LOOKING AT PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMES. RE UNFORTUNATELY- FROM
DATING BACK TO THEIR VERY EARLY
YEARS ARE YOU HAVE TO DO IS
VISIT THE FOSTER HOMES WHERE WE
HAVE THE BABIES WHICH I'VE
DONE. MANY TIMES AND WONDER HOW
THAT LITTLE BABY ALL BECAME
SUCH A DANGER- AND NOW IT'S YOU
KNOW. VERY HIGH SECURITY PRISON
ANSWER ONLY A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS AND HAVE
YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE A SATANIC.
DRIVES SO YOU'VE SEEN IT ALL.
AND I THINK. YOU ARE A GREAT-
CENTRIST. ON WHETHER. THIS
APPROACH FOR REHABILITATION.
GIVE WERE. WHAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE IT BETTER. WHAT AND WHAT.
ON A SCALE OF ONE TO TEN WHERE
YOU THINK WE ARE BECAUSE IT'S
NEWER CERTAINLY NEWER ALL RIGHT
TO- THE PROFESSION CLEARLY AND
WHAT OF WHAT YOU ENVISIONED FOR
THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL ON RECIDIVISM IF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AND I I'M
NOT GONNA ASK THE CITY
QUESTIONS I'M JUST GOING TO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE. YOUR HISTORY WITH THAT
YOU WOULDN'T STILL BE THERE I
DON'T BELIEVE UNLESS SHE
BELIEVED IN WHAT IS STARTING TO
HAPPEN IN THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
IS THERE IN OTHER WORDS THE BIG
H. WORD HOPE THERE IS HOPE THAT
YOU CAN TAKE AND MODIFY
BEHAVIOR. ARE EVEN THOUGH
PERSONS OLDER AND PUT THEM BACK
INTO SOCIETY AS A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER AND SOMEBODY TO ENJOY
THE OPPORTUNITIES OF FREEDOM
THAT IS SO FUNDAMENTAL TO LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS WHICH UPON WHICH THIS
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED SO IF YOU
COULD SHARE THAT WITH ME- THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND I BELIEVE
THIS MEETING WITH A MORE
POSITIVE VIEW. IN WE START WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THE DARKER
SIDE OF CORRECTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR I THINK ABSOLUTELY-
HOPE THE REHABILITATION. ARE IS
WORKING- AS I SAID EARLIER- IN
MY OPENING STATEMENT I STARTED-
IN AT THAT TIME WERE
ORGANIZATION APARTMENT WERE.
YOU AWARE HOW CD COURSE RATED
PEOPLE AB WAS AT A VERY
VIOLENT- TIME IN IN OUR
HISTORY- I THINK WERE BETTER AT
WHAT WE DO TODAY I THINK OUR
ORGANIZATION UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF REHABILITATION
THAT UNDERSTANDING. THE WHOLE
HI IT'S- WHERE HE- IT'S SO
EXCITING TO GO INTO SOME OF OUR
HIGH SECURITY PRISONS SOME OF
THEM WERE MENTIONED EARLIER IN
THIS HEARING. IN C. R.
EMPLOYEES WITH SMILES ON THEIR
FACE AND CULTURALLY PEOPLE BACK
YOU KNEW EARLIER IN YOUR
CAREER- MAYBE NOT ME PERSONALLY
BUT I'M WALKING WITH SOMEBODY
WHO KNEW THAT ICARCERATED
PERSON TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO. HE AND- THEY NEVER THOUGHT
THAT THEY WERE GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY WHEN YOU'RE SITTING
IN SPEAK WITH OUR OUR
POPULATION THE WOULD HAVE NEVER
ENVISIONED THEMSELVES THERE AND
UNDERSTANDING YOU FOR. OUR OF
REHABILITATION AND SO WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT GIVING BACK IN THAT
BE TAKEN SO MUCH FROM SOCIETY
THAT WERE GIVEN HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE BACK AND
THAT'S THAT GOES A LONG WAY
FOR- OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME IS AN EMPLOYEE WELLNESS.
ARMS SAFE SECURE FACILITIES ARE
THOSE ALL IMPORTANT THINGS BUT
IT ALSO GOES A LONG WAY YOU ARE
COMMUNITIES INDIVIDUAL IS
RELEASED BACK IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT IMPACTS. SO MANY PEOPLE
NOT JUST GRAPPLING COURSE
LEADER PERSON THEY HAVE WIVES
THEY HAVE HUSBANDS THEY HAVE
DAUGHTERS. COUSINS FAMILIES.
FRIENDS THAT THEN WE POSITIVE
IN ARE COMMUNITY. ARE B. O. B.
OF THAT HAVE NON WORK. IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF OUR OF OUR
PRISON SYSTEMS ACTION BENEFIT
FROM THE LIKE FOOD IN DIFFERENT-
S. FROM THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION SO I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE YOU SPOKE ABOUT THAT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THAT UP SENATOR IT'S EXTREMELY
WELL AND I'M A BIG RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE- ON AVERAGE IT I THINK
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I
THINK HAVING OFTENTIMES FROM A
DEFENSE PERSPECTIVE WE DON'T
SPEAK ABOUT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
FAIR IN ALL. THE TIMES YOU HEAR
FROM VICTIMS REYES JR FROM ARM
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY ON
CRIMES IN OUR. IN OUR AND
COMMUNITIES AND- THEY NEED THAT
FOR THEM SO TO ON HIS WAY HE-
IN ONE PER- SPOKE ABOUT HI
AUBURN- THAT THEY HAD TO SHOOT
AMENDS WITH. THE PERSON THAT-
ARMS VICTIMIZE DAMAGE IN THE
SAID THAT AFTER THAT THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO THE MOVE ON THE IN
THE IN THE FOUNDER THEY WERE
CONTINUING TO VICTIMIZE
THEMSELVES UNTIL THEY GOT THAT
OPPORTUNITY SO. THERE'S A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS HERE NOW WITH
THAT BEING SAID DO YOU- DO I
THINK. WE ARE WE NEED TO BE ARE
WE WANT TO BE AT THE END NO I
THINK WE ARE CONTINUE TO DO
GOOD THINGS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR OUR OUR LEADERSHIP GROUPS
IN THE IN THE FIELD- SUPPORTER
INCARCERATED PERSONS IN FIELD.
CELEBRATE THE SMALL SUCCESSES
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT YOU VALLEY MAY NOT BE
HUMONGOUS THEY ARE IN IN FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW
ATTENDING GRADUATIONS WHEN I'M
AFTER. THE INSTITUTION SPEAKING
WITH NOT ONLY OUR STAFF WRITER
GROCERY I THINK THAT GOES A
LONG WAY. I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ONGOING
FORWARD SHARK RESEARCH. FOR YOU
HAVE GIVEN ME THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU I MEAN NOT NOT TO BE
A PROBABLY A BUT ON BEING AT
ALL PSYCH MAJORS IT THERE A
GREAT. WHICH IS DECADE OLD NOW
THE DARK LIKE. THE SKIN. A
STEADY THAT WAY AND THE PEOPLE
ARE. WITH AN- OF BILL LERNER
AND THE WOULD BE. TAKE A LITTLE
LONGER THAT YET LAST MUCH
LONGER PERHAPS A LIFETIME AND
THAT THAT'S I THINK WHAT BUT
WHAT THE GOAL IS HERE BUT IT'S
A VERY DIFFICULT ONE TO OBTAIN.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SPENT A LIFETIME ON THE WRONG
SIDE YOU KNOW OF THE LAW AND-
GROWING U IN A SOCIETY THAT.
PROBABLY PROMOTES THAT FRANKLY
WE KNOW THAT WITH THE GAMES
AND- THE GAMES THAT ARE LISTED
IN HERE YOU GOT YOUR RYAN RYAN
NATION. AS NUMBER ONE- I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER WAS PUT ON THE TOP
I THOUGHT THAT WAS. PERHAPS NOT
ACCURATE BECAUSE I THINK SOME
OF THE LONG TERM. GAINS THAT
HAVE BEEN THERE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT. WALKS OF LIFE- AND-
WHAT CRIME THEY'RE INVOLVED
WITH THEY'RE PROBABLY ALL EQUAL
AND THEY SEEM TO HAVE A VERY
DOMINANT ROLE INSIDE THE PRISON
WALLS SO THEY WOULDN'T BE HIGH
ON REHABILITATION BECAUSE THEY
STILL WANT TO MAINTAIN POWER SO
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
VERY AWARE OF THAT. THAT LAST
QUESTION IS GOING TO BE ABOUT
THE FOLKS THAT YOU ARE LETTING
OUT WITH A- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
ORIGINALLY AND NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND. SO WHAT SORT OF
SCREENING IS DONE IN TERMS OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS HOOTERS WHO
SUPPOSEDLY ARE HAVING THEIR
SENTENCES REDUCED BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN. THREE REBEL ATTACK
REHABILITATION- AND HAVE A GOOD
CREDIT FOR. THAT ARE MANY OF
THEM ARE IN THERE BECAUSE THEY
USE GUNS. IT USED TO BE USED
AGAIN GO TO GO TO PRISON. AND
IT WHERE THOSE PEOPLE ARE OUT
AND THEY STILL HAVE THE ACCESS
TO. A GUN- ILLEGAL GUNS- THAT
IS VERY TROUBLING THAT EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE. PLAYING THE
GAME YOU HAVE TO HAVE A PER SO
OF THESE P. WHO ARE. REALLY
WANTING TO. BE REAL BILL IN TO
GET BACK TO THE RIGHT SIDE BUT
YOU GO A PURSE. OF USING A BELL
CURVE WHICH IS USED WITH MANY
OF THE STUDIES. THERE ARE THOSE
WHO PLAINLY GAMING THE SYSTEM.
IT WOULD SEEM TO BE THE
SCREENING THAT'S DONE ON THE
RELEASE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
ARE TO REALLY DIG DEEPER IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEIR CRIMES WERE
IN THEIR ACCESS TO GUNS. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT SORT OF
SCREENING YOU DO THAT'S ANOTHER
THING I'D LIKE YOU TO INCLUDE.
ON THE FILE YOU KNOW
INFORMATION GOING TO. PROVIDE
AND- YOU KNOW REQUEST OF OUR
PRO TEM. THAT IS WHAT I'D LIKE
YOU TO COVER. WHAT SORT OF
SCREENING IS DONE. WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THE MULTIPLE CRIMES
MAYBE OFFENSE ENHANCEMENTS.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
UNPOPULAR PRESENTLY BUT IF YOU
GOT A SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT FOR
USING A GUN AND YOU KILLED
SOMEBODY WITH THAT. THEM TO ME
THAT PERSON GET OR THE BACK OF
THE LINE IN TERMS A GOOD
CREDIT. BECAUSE THAT. FRANKLY
THEY HAVE ACCESS. AND THEY KNOW
HOW TO GET HIM. AND THEY ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF GRIEVANCES ARE
THEY'RE GOING TO FATAL AND
THERE ARE. MANY OF THEM ARE
ALREADY YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
GAME'S AFFILIATION. ABOUT FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY-
COMMUNICATING WITH OUTSIDE OF
THE PRISON WALLS. SO THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT RIGHT NOW BUT IF
YOU WOULD INCLUDE. A DISCUSSION
IN YOUR LETTER OF WHAT SORT OF
SCREENING IS DONE ON. MULTIPLE
pENHANCEMENT. IT IS YOU. HI
COMMITTEE A CRIME. THIS TAKING
LIFE FOR. BY ENTRY. OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND YOU'RE IN THERE
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN THERE THREE TIMES
FOR THE SAME CRIME. I THINK A
LOT MORE A DEEPER DIVE ON
WHETHER THAT PERSON CAN REALLY
BE. REHABILITATED IN THE SHORT
TERM HI IT NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THIS OR WE WILL NOT GET THE
PUBLIC. ON BOARD WITH. THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE APPROACH
AND BEING COMFORTABLE THAT
WE'RE NOT LETTING PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW OUT OF PRISON NOW GOING TO
LIVE NEXT DOOR TO THEM. AND
BECAUSE ARE PRESENTING
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT DANGER
TO THEM. THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
COMMUNITY AND YOUR HEARING THAT
A LOT I'M SURE. SO I WILL YOU
KNOW AND WITHOUT. AND HOPE THAT
YOU WILL PROVIDE FROM DEEPER
DISCUSSION ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES I WILL ENSURE
THAT- THE STAFF CONNECTS WITH
YOU TO MORE SPECIFICALLY MAKE
SURE- THAT WE GET THAT
ARTICULATED- SO THAT- MISSILES
ON A WILL BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
IT. SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I KNOW THIS
HEARINGS RUNNING LIGHT WE'VE
GOT ANOTHER THING TO COME IN
THIS. ROOM IN THE NOT TOO
DISTANT FUTURES IT AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE- QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE CENTER COM WALKER.
ARE DEALING WITH THE
TRANSITIONS AND I KNOW THAT.
YOU ARE THE OF AUSTRAC IS THE
FOURTH OF THE FIFTH PERSON.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO COME IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
LAST MONTH OR SO AND SO WE HAVE
VETTED THIS WITH MANY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE SO I JUST. THINK I HAVE
ONE QUESTION THAT HASN'T BEEN
ASKED AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY AND IT RELATES TO
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY ELSE'S
BEEN. TALKING ABOUT AND IT'S
MORE MANAGERIAL. THE E. FROM A
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE HOW DO
YOU. MONITOR WHAT GOES ON IN
EVERY SINGLE INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTION WHAT'S YOUR
STRUCTURE THAT'S IN PLACE STEP
WHEN THESE ISSUES ARE RAISED IN
THE COMMITTEE. YOU FEEL LIKE
FROM A CENTRAL ADMINISTRATIVE
ROLE YOUR ON TOP OF THAT. THANK
YOU SENATOR PER QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THAT. ARE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF REVIEW THAT WE HAVE
AND HOW WE MONITOR THE
OPERATIONS OF OUR OUR PRISONS
WE NEEDED A SPECIFIC OPERATIONS
I SPOKE ABOUT- SOME OF THEM
EARLIER WITH OUR MONTHLY
BUDGET- WE HAVE A HOT BUDGET
FORECASTING FUNCTION THAT WE
REQUIRE ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
TO REPORT MONTHLY WHAT'S
DRIVING HER BUDGET- WE- WE HAVE
SYSTEMS IN WHICH WE CAN
IDENTIFY- IN WORKING HAND IN
HAND WITH OUR BUDGET SHOP- WE
MEET WITH THEM. ON YOUR
HEADQUARTERS ON A MONTHLY BASIS
HOLMER TRENDS WE LOOK AT THINGS
IN THE YEAR I REPORTS. LIKE OUR
AUDIT REPORT. THE ANSWER ARE.
IN OR EAT ARE ALL TIMES OF THE
DAY IN IN I ALWAYS CHUCKLE I
SEE THE BUT IT'S ABSOLUTE TRUE
WE GET. A PHONE CALL. AND ARMY
EMAIL IN WE LIVE AND WE DON'T
HERE BUT WE LISTEN TO OUR
STAKEHOLDERS MILLICENT YOU ARM
ARE INCARCERATED PERSONS
FAMILIES WE FOLLOW UP ON AYE
INQUIRES. I LIKE THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM IN WHICH WE MONITOR-
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THE
OPERATIONS OF THE PRISON ON A
MONTHLY BASIS I SPOKE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT. THE WONDERFUL
TEAM I HAVE WORKING WITH ME
HERE AT THE HEADQUARTERS IN THE
PROVIDE THE REPORTS THEY
PROVIDE EACH DIFFERENT THINGS
ON ON ON WHAT I ASKED THEM. TO
DO BASED ON OUR- I ONLY WE'VE
DONE BUT TO BE. IN AGAIN-
MATRIX THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE- GO IN JUNE. DEFICIENCY OR
SAY. THERE'S A BUNCH OF OTHER
THINGS WE ARE WE I PERSONALLY.
ACCORDING THE BASES ARE. ARE WE
CALL I ACTUALLY IN THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES THEY MEET THE WORD
MEANS THEY HAVE HE- THEY HAVE A
MEETING WHERE. ARE THE WALDOS
HIM OR HER THE ALSO WRITE DOWN
ON AN AGENDA THEY TALKING I
REDUCE LUMINANCE AND MOM
LOCALLY AT THE INSTITUTIONS I
AM TALKING WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AS WISELY.
ACTIVITIES ON- FOLLOWING UP ON
ITEMS THAT I FOUND IN OUR
pARE CON COMPARISON STATISTICS
REPORTER ALSO KNOWN AS A
CONCEPT REPORT. ARE WE LOOKING
AT USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS ON A
REGULAR BASIS ESPECIALLY WITH
AND- THE MISSION HERE UP IN
HIGH SECURITY WE SPEAK WITH ARE
ON BUDGET MN WHO WERE OUT IN
OUR FACILITIES TO BE.
ACCORDINGLY HE AND WITH THEM
AND THEY ARE ALWAYS IN NEED
BOLD TO OUR NAY EVEN SPEAK WITH
MEDIAN FOLLOW UP ON A ITEMS
THAT. IT YOU'RE DOING. YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB I DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE. A SHORT CIRCUIT YOU
MAY NEED A THE LAST THING TO
ASK ABOUT THAT IS. DO YOU HAVE
SOME SORT OF. WHAT DO YOU SAY
DO ALL THE YOU US TO OF A- MAN.
SO THAT IF YOU HAVE A- THAT
HAVE TO. YOU INTO THOSE IN. IN
YOUR TO FOR OUT YOU CAN ADAPT
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU CHANGE
PROCEDURES OR- OR CHANGE THINGS
TO WORK TO THOSE THINGS NEVER
HAPPENING THAT WAY AGAIN IS. IS
THAT WHAT YOU USE ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS FOR THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED. ABSOLUTELY NOT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP
SENATORS AND A APPRECIATE THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY WE LOOK AT- WE
GET UPDATED EVERY DAY OF OUR
CRITICAL INCIDENTS HAPPEN. FOR
INCIDENTS THAT OCCURRED WITHIN
OUR FACILITIES AND SO WHAT WE
DO IS- WHENEVER WE'RE LOOKING
AND IN DOING A- ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS OF AN INCIDENT OR
SITUATION THAT OCCURRED WHEN
OUR FACILITIES. WE USE THAT
INFORMATION ALONG WITH ALL OF
THESE OTHER THINGS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DIRECTOR. I IN THE SECRETARY
NUMBER UNDERSECRETARIES POLICY
REVISIONS- THINGS OF THAT
NATURE HELLO WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND JUST WAITING
TO EVEN GET TO THIS HEARING AND
FOR THE LIFE OF THE HEARING AND
FOR YOUR GOOD RESPONSIVENESS.
APPRECIATE THANK YOU MADAM JUST.
THANK YOU SEEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED HI- IN A
INTEREST TOM I'M HAVE SOME KIND.
COMMENTS BUT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. AND I'M JUST GONNA SAY
NOW I'M GOING TO TAKE MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT OF AND OPPOSITION
AND ASK YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION- AT A I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET YOUR- YOUR.
COMMITTEE MEETING THAT IS
SCHEDULED HERE THAT IS THE
DILEMMA THAT WE HAVE. ARE UNDER
CODE NINETEEN SO WHAT I'M GOING
TO DO IS GO AHEAD AND PUT THE
REMINDER UP AGAIN FOR PEOPLE
WISHING TO CALL IN. TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE THAT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS%
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE THE ACCESS
CODEIS SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN
NINE EIGHT SEVEN. BUT I'M GOING
TO BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I DO NOT
SEE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. LOOKING AT
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I ALSO SEE
THAT NO ONE IS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO MISTER MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU AND SEE
IF YOU CAN T. UP PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. CHECK IN TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A CONNECTION
AND WELCOME BACK OUR MODERATOR
FOR. TELECONFERENCE PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT. MAYBE FOR ONCE THE
MODERATORS. I WERE WERE
CHECKING.
WHAT WE'RE CHECKING
IT MAY TAKE JUST A MINUTE.
RIGHT RIGHT. I. WELL THESE
THINGS DO HAPPEN I. WHAT WE
WILL JUST ARE GIVEN ANOTHER
MINUTE STAFFER ARE YOU
SERIOUSLY WORKING HARD TO TRY
AND DEAL WITH THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES LET ME SAY THIS
WHILE WE'RE TRYING- I WAS GOING
TO HOLD MY COMMENTS- I THINK
FROM. YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED
THAT OUR MISSILES AUTO- IN THE
VERY OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT
CHANGING CULTURE AND- I REALLY
THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN HERE
FOR A LITTLE WHILE AND I'VE
BEEN ON THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THE LAST WELL MY ENTIRE TIME
HERE A NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES-
I HAVE BEEN ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW CDCR IS DIFF
DIFFICULT IN MANY RESPECTS
BECAUSE WE HAVE ASPIRATIONS FOR
WHAT REHABILITATION MEANS. WE
HAVE ALL THE CONCERN THAT
INMATES ARE TREATED A CERTAIN
WAY INCARCERATED AND WE ALSO
HAVE EXPECTATIONS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
OF OTHERS IS PARAMOUNT AND YOU
HAVE A DIFFICULT CHARGE IT AS
ADMINISTRATION- WE'VE WORKED
VERY HARD WITHIN OUR OWN.
INSTITUTION HERE IN THE SENATE
TO CHANGE ISSUES OF CULTURE
AROUND EXPECTATIONS OF- YOU
KNOW RESPECT RESPECT AND
SUPPORT FOR ALL EMPLOYEES IN
THE DIVERSITY THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN OUR OWN RANKS AND HOW WE
TREAT EACH OTHER. TO THE DEGREE
THAT WE'VE CREATED A WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT BECAUSE WE WANT
OUR STAFF AND THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK HERE- AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ENGAGE IN
INTERACT WITH US TO FEEL- LIKE
THEY ARE SAFE THAT THEY ARE
RESPECTED AND THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT SO WE'VE
HAD OUR OWN CHALLENGES ON
CULTURE CHANGE AND WE ARE STILL
IN THE MIDST OF THAT THAT IS
NOT A- YOU GET THERE YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL YOU'VE DONE IT IT IS
A PROCESS AND- AND WE CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. I I AGREE WITH MY
VICE CHAIR OF THAT THIS IS A
VERY AND THE OTHERS WHO SAID
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT JOB WE
EXPECT A LOT OF YOU. AND YOU
ARE ONE PIECE OF IT YOU ARE NOT
IN CHARGE OF EVERY ASPECT- I DO
THINK- IF YOU TAKE ANYTHING
AWAY FROM THIS IT'S THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE JOB YOU DO WE
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY- IN TERMS OF
OVERSIGHT AND CONFIRMATION AND
WE DO IT THROUGH THE SENATE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS BUT WE
ALSO DO IT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND WE DO IT THERE
POLICY HEARINGS WHEN WE CHANGE
OR PROPOSED CHANGES TO
LEGISLATION. THOSE ARE THE WAYS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOB AND
WE DO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND I
DO NOT ASSUME TO KNOW WHAT IT
COULD POSSIBLY BE LIKE TO DO
YOUR JOB OR TO BE INCARCERATED
FRANKLY. KNOCK ON WOOD AS I SAY
THAT- BUT I- I DO THINK THAT
HOPE WE IMPRESS UPON YOU THAT
WE CERTAINLY HOPE AND EXPECT
THAT YOU WILL BE PART OF THE
CULTURE CHANGE THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN- IN THE SYSTEM. ALL THAT
IS THE LARGEST PRISON SYSTEM IN
THE WORLD. AND THAT BALANCE
THAT YOU HAVE TO CREATE.
BETWEEN WORKING WITH- GUARDS
AND STAFF. TO ACT RESPONSIBLY
PROFESSIONALLY AND TREAT
EVERYBODY WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE
FOLLOW AT THE SAME TIME SEEM
PROBABLY SOME OF THE WORST OF
HUMANITY- AND HELL THAT BEARS-
IN WHAT YOU DO- SO THOSE WERE
JUST MY COMMENTS I INTENDED
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT YOU TODAY.
AND I WILL MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STAFF GET YOU US A SINGLE LIST
OF. QUESTIONS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE RESPONSES TO THAT YOU
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF AT AT
CDC ARE NEED MINISTRATION. CAN
RESPONSE WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF SOME OF THE
POLICIES. THAT YOU CAN FOLLOW-
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TOM. AND
I'M LOOKING AT MY STAFF NOW TO
SEE IF. I AM HAPPY TO WELCOME
BACK- I THINK IT IS GONNA STILL
BE MISTER MODERATOR I WILL
CHANGE THE PROGRAM NOW IF I
NEED TO- WELCOME BACK AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL WORKING OUT WITH US.
CORES LEAVING GERMAN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND. ZERO AND
WE WILL HAVE YOU STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION OF ANY
YOU SUPPORT AND YOUR SUPPORT.
OR AT THIS POINT YOUR SUPPORT
OF MISTER LOZANO. AND THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO ONE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR I THE FEELING WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT
SO DON'T HANG UP- LET ME TURN
TO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ROOM
I STILL SEE NO ONE- FROM THE
PUBLIC HERE TO SPEAK THIS WOULD
BE IN OPPOSITION. R. OKAY I AM
LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
SEE NO ONE APPROACH IN THE
DIETS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
MISTER MODERATOR THIS WOULD BE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO TEE UP ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR ASSISTANCE TODAY WE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP- I WILL
BRING THIS BACK TO US AND
SENATOR LAYERED SOMEONE HAD
MOVE OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
THIS NOMINEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. WE WISH YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK MADAM
SECRETARY- WE HAVE A MOTION
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
WE HAVE A MOTION IN SUPPORT.
CALL THE ROLL. ONE B. LOZANO
GROWTH HI I KAMLAGER HI
MARGARET I LAYERED BY AYE BATES
AYE AYE ATKINS AYE BACK INSIDE
IT IS UNANIMOUS MISTER LOZANO
AND- WE WILL BE IN TOUCH
CONGRADULATIONS. THANK THE
LONGER MUCH I APPRECIATE TIME
THANK YOU OKAY- LET ME JUST-
SAY THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S
PUBLIC PORTION OF THE AGENDA I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS
BECAUSE YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO BE SURE
AND INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
WITH THAT- THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO
EXECUTIVE SESSION- VERY QUICKLY
THANK YOU ALL.